so now there are calls to boycott Disney
the mainstream media is picking it up
and there are a bunch of photos popping
up all over X of people showing they've
canceled their subscriptions to all of
these companies that announced
Advertiser boycotts on X after Elon Musk
said go f yourself you will not
blackmail me essentially many people
joined in and now there's big pushes for
people to sign up for X premium and to
cancel s their subscription to any one
of these companies stop servicing these
companies to boycott any company that
played politics to put it simply this is
not just a company being like well we
don't want to run ads on X anymore it's
all of these companies at the same time
teaming up with political activists to
negatively impact a business that isn't
taking the political stance they want
this should get very very interesting so
we'll talk about that we've got the CEO
of X doubling down and telling all of
the staff we believe in free speech and
we won't back down from this from from
their position awesome
and then of course Donald Trump praising
uh and thanking black lives matter for
their support despite the fact it was
just one guy but this is a funny story
now a lot of conservatives are saying he
should not be thanking them and then of
course we've got just Trump is gaining a
ton of support in New York among black
and Latino voter and there's on the
ground interviews talking about this and
and and where gets interesting he's
actually got potential support now not
just for Michael Rapaport but Chris
Cuomo on the pbd podcast saying he's
open to voting for Donald Trump wow
it's going to get really interesting
before we get started my friends head
over to cast brew.com and buy coffee
this will be the best cup of coffee You'
ever had I guarantee it I think I can
say that because I don't know what it
quite means to have the best cup of
coffee other than I really do think
appalachin Knights is the best cup of
coffee I've ever had and I think you'll
agree but you can also check out other
Blends we got rise with robberto JR we
got Mr Bokus pumpkin spice experience we
got stand your grounds we got K cups for
those that like those we got ground
coffee and we got whole bean coffee
support Casper they support support the
show this is our company and we are
expanding into physical locations
currently under construction with your
help we're going to have a thousand
locations in five years maybe I don't
know we're hoping to get a bunch of
locations up but that's the big Vision
also head over to
timcast.net friendly things and it's a
lot of fun you as members can join the
Discord server call in submit questions
and actually talk to us and our guests
so don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this YouTube channel
right now and share this show take the
URL post it wherever you can if you
really want to help out joining us
tonight to talk about this and a whole
lot more we got Ryan long and Danny
polish yo we' actually planned to show
up here in full blackface but Tim
actually censored us he doesn't want the
viewers knowing that so well the issue
was that half your face was red and I
was like what do you you guys doing
that's not funny that kid got in trouble
the plan was if we do half him red half
me black and then we sort of stand next
to each other do style we will have the
full effect that was a fun music video
yeah okay so everyone figed out your
comedians yep hello welcome just
non-stop with these guys I will say with
the with the Elon Musk stuff there is
you can even I'm sure you've said no to
uh Advertiser but if you're like a
public company and you do that it's
illegal right but if being to do that
must have been sick because you've
probably said no to an Advertiser and
does make you feel like quite the big
man yeah yeah there like but but this is
I I think it's simple to say it's
illegal but you're most mostly true you
have a fiduciary responsibility to make
money and someone comes to you and
offers you a bunch of money if you don't
have a legitimate reason for rejecting
it dude you can't just run the company
to the ground and being like yeah I'm
just doing my thing it's like you be at
the very least you'd be fired like FCC
violations so I guess you that's the
whole reason why you have a private
company is you're like I can do whatever
I want so Elon can say go off yourselves
yeah well he is that's going to be
that's what I mean as an individual
podcaster where you're like I'm done
with this ad because I didn't like he's
just doing that to the entire industry
good well we'll talk about that more
thanks for hanging out guys should be a
blast we got Hannah Clair brolo hanging
out hey I'm Hannah Clair I'm a writer
for cnr.com otherwise known as scanner
news I really like it there Ian's back
hello everyone I'm back from lukowski's
uh castle in the mountains uh in uh
Miami it was great and it's good to be
back let's rock and roll yeah let's get
it done Tim when I just want I just want
to mention real quick too uh nome's
debating Dan santis tonight I want to
see it and you know it's it's going to
be at 9: and we're having this conver
like I'm having this conversation before
the show like do we do we comment on it
like do we do we watch it and everyone
just shrugs like ask the chat
why get the point of it yeah I mean look
it is fair to say you've got red State
versus Blue State mentality but I just
feel like a lot of people are hyping it
up because desis is running for
president but look if if if Fox News
announced they were going to have you
know in you know politician a versus
politician B and they're just totally
irrelevant to the cycle I just be like
well okay that's fine they do Town Halls
all the time I'm down with what Hannah
Clair said maybe we could put a poll in
there and see if the audience really
wants it if it's like 75% yes it's a
commitment man because it's it's an hour
and a half long and it's like if we want
to actually watch it I just kind of feel
like might be a major snooze Fest like
Tim says this a privately run podcast
he's going to make the decisions here I
want to see if they're like laughing it
up and it's like oh these guys get along
or if it's super lame we'll probably
take a peek at it age on everything but
I feel like it's going to be a total
snooze between two guys who don't matter
to the presidential cycle maybe maybe
new some runs has there ever been
something like it like like this where
just two Governors just debate each
other for during a presidential cycle
and one's a candidate and one's not it
just it's weird is there a Poss ability
that you hear like a glass shattering
sound and then Trump does come through
for the
rap he jumps off jumps off the Raptors
and swings down orange paint just sprays
on the audience they get they get was it
what was it slimed yeah well I don't
know so we'll see what happens later but
let's jump into the first story we got
this from Newsweek Disney faces renewed
boycott calls it's not just Disney but I
love how this made it to Newsweek they
say things are heating up for Disney
with the company facing fresh boycott
calls continuing on from its
announcement that the brand was ceasing
advertising with X formerly Twitter just
days ago several leading Global Brands
including Disney announced their we we
we get they're boting boycotting X Elon
Musk then said go f yourselves and in
response to this we got a bunch of
people on X posting photos of them
canceling their Disney plus
subscriptions now I just want to stress
I canceled mine a long time ago after
Disney Plus thank to the security forces
in China who are running the weager
concentration camps where they force
women to get abortions and let's just
say that is it is very very brutal what
they're doing to those people so uh I'm
not I'm not too happy with what Disney's
doing and I don't want them to have my
money but now it's piling up they're
also calling for boycotts of all of
these other companies so it it'll be
interesting will will X be able to
survive just off of subscription
memberships I kind of feel like how much
is the the ad revenue for how much is
100 million a
year Andrew Tate said he would do a mill
didn't you say You' do so he said he' do
a million a month million a month to
advertise X I said 100K a month I said
100K a month for three months and I
think you said a mill so we have another
Mill can we B half a mill they were
doing 250,000 a month but they doubled
it to 500,000 so then you're talking
about 50 m year after stuff like that
and it's probably closer to 30 Mill year
where it's like I think a guy like him
doesn't really care that much about that
type of numbers yeah I wonder what
they're going to do I thought maybe that
they would end up shuttering the
centralized service and turn into a
decentralized protocol because they've
been talking about using Noster and he's
been working with Jack dorsy uh Elon
Noster is like uh what was your question
I was I was saying who's using yeah yeah
that they would like join the fediverse
and then make Twitter X more of a
protocol that you would use like a
centralized peer-to-peer communication
system so like we'd all host it on our
devices and if like half of them go down
the system's still running on everybody
else's device just poured in so it would
cut the cost of servers and I don't know
what their bulk costs are I know when he
bought the company slash a bunch of the
employee count this is actually a really
good point e this this could be a clever
play for Elon where they finally get
Twitter onto a decentralized system
where no one can be banned ever again he
says we're not even it's not even up to
us yeah so if they go I I don't know if
you're saying Noster Noster yeah but or
or what the other one uh um the
fediverse MH the ferse so these are like
protocols where anyone can plug into any
other one basically like the internet if
Elon Musk says Twitter is now going to
be open source and Federated that means
you could be signed up for gab and tell
someone oh if you're follow me you know
Ryan gab.com and then if someone's on X
they can type that in and follow you
wherever they are so this would mean
that X Twitter whatever could no longer
ban anybody wouldn't that be like
destroying his investment though though
like the if the company is going to go
under because Advertiser is canceled
yeah and then he's just like well the
company's dead unless we open source and
Federate also if you open source you
could put stuff in where if if there is
advertisement for every million dollars
Disney pulls another censorship person
gets fired and just have that trigger
set up and just be like well it's up to
you it's not out of my control right now
the thing's set up HR person goes for
100 grand and a million dollars we go a
censorship person oh like smart
contracts smart contract it just
triggers firings according to
how much money Disney pulls sort of hold
them hostage on that leverage I kind of
get the vibe that this is the direction
Not only would it be great for Humanity
to have a a system like Twitter or X
whatever you want to call it on the
fediverse I mean that's the big deal you
got mines and Mastadon and things like
that on the fediverse gab you mentioned
earlier but Elon has blatantly stated
he's not in it for the money and he
never was he's in it for Humanity and
free speech and things like that I bet
his investors are like yeah we're we're
kind of for the money a bit the CEO had
to come up with the statement being like
well we really liked Elon I mean he like
again like he has a lot of investors who
probably like
yeah Humanity but you could also run ads
on a decentralized service there's no
need that it would ever really even
disrupt the ad revenue and then actually
he could come out and say we're going to
decentralize the service Federate which
means we're not going to be responsible
for any hate speech because it's out of
our hands and we can still control
advertising so we can make all the money
with none of the downside that's a play
right there it mean if you Federated
that the advertisements get seen by more
people too theoretically that's an
interesting concept probably not
Federated advertising is a nice way to
go in the future it is but he would have
to so basically the way that would work
is the idea of Federated social media is
imagine if like how the internet works
you can open a browser and go to any
website you would be a member at on X
and you could choose to follow any other
Federated account from any other website
so let's say you know you're on X and
someone's on Facebook you could you
could go on to X and follow someone's
Facebook but the owners of x if they're
in the federis could say we want to
Blacklist all accounts from facebook.com
and then you can't see it through the
Facebook node but if you go to like
Mastadon you can still see the Facebook
no l they get to choose where something
like nost is way more open and you can't
stop anything but you I think it's fair
that that a service can say we don't
want to connect to this service that's
fine but if Elon was selling ads on X
they would not appear outside of X but
if he federates you could sign up for I
don't know truth social if truth social
Federated you could follow Trump on X
from his truth Social account so like it
basically connects does TR social have
to allow it though yes okay so so truth
which I isn't truth Mastadon it was
based on Mastadon I can't imagine
they're going to want to though because
isn't that the whole reason that Trump's
not tweeting is because he has right
they want to make money they want to
make money and they're like you can't go
over to our competitors the big the
bigger question I have for you guys cuz
you guys make a uh uh deeply deeply
offensive and shocking edgy content is I
mean what do what what do you think
about these companies I mean Disney
recently announced that they're
misaligned with the public one of the
problems with like companies like Disney
in general sort of like Coke where you
go even if someone goes oh I'm gonna
boycott that and you go just so you know
they own all all the other 45 others
like you it's impossible to even
remember who they own and stuff like
that right this it's very I bet you Coke
does or someone yeah probably you know
you seen the thing where it's like three
companies own every
single they own ESPN they own I mean my
main issue with Disney is I'm banned
from all their parks for life but
uh St well you're not the bottom line is
streaking is a night time
activity no uh I don't know I don't I
don't really watch any Disney stuff like
I'm not like into Star Wars like you
guys watch like Star Wars like the
Mandalorian I only watched it on and
that stuff after episode one came out I
lost but they made like a ton of movies
where you don't even realize that was a
Disney film I was done with Mandalore
when they fired Jano I'm like dude if
you so and that's the start of it but
when they so I had a year membership and
then I bought the year in advance when
they when they when the weager Muslim
thing came out where they thanked the
security forces I'm like yo those people
are like mercilessly torturing human
beings and we all know so I'm not I'm
done with this and then with Mandalorian
I mean Gina corano that whole stuff I
was like this company's garbage yeah the
crazy thing is like their stock is not
doing well so you think that they
actually would be like whole reason that
Bob Iger got brought back is cuz he was
going to you know stop all this nonsense
I feel like that was the whole thing is
that Bob Iger the other guy went in
right that guy was tanking it and then
he sort of came back from the grave
being like I'm taking the r back so I
feel like to some degree being he
probably will put a kind of an end to
some of the stuff but obviously but it's
probably just ceremonial right they're
saying oh look board members we have
brought Bob back and so things will be
okay he never actually committed to
changing any ideology well I bet with
the movie like cuz all their movies keep
bombing but like the thing is like those
Cycles is those movies probably went
into development four years ago when
probably at the time you go like oh yeah
this stuff is going to be around forever
we're going to all this raw ra stuff a
great idea yeah this is a great idea
right now and nobody's thinking
everyone's going to watch Marvel's 40
times exactly yeah if if it came out
today it would be a huge hit and then
now I watch it 35 tops and they probably
their production schedule is like yeah
this will be out like 2022 and then it
gets push back two years or whatever a
year and then people are like this sucks
I I just want to point out this is made
by it's it's owned by the private
company Spindrift and founder they have
105 employees and he grew up on a farm
in Massachusetts I think that's what
they said and so uh think you dig a
little further that guy's last name is
Pepsi yeah they took a $29 million
investment from mullus and Company LLC
in 2020 drifted yeah
that's by vmg Partners so those are the
two big companies that where where do I
find that that was on Wikipedia history
yeah oh really yeah subsidary of a
subsidary mean they are SOL prodct
that's what they do that's what they do
they like Starbucks this I I read this
in the newspaper so maybe it's not true
but my understanding Starbucks will open
a coffee shop and called like Mom and
Pops and then you go they're like oh I
don't want to go to Starbucks and you're
actually buying from Starbucks yeah I
got you Starbucks is my favorite one how
they play all this stuff stuff cuz a lot
of times they'll do you know some super
Progressive thing about like refugees
and then people get mad and then they
replace it with veterans and they get
mad and they replace it back with
refugees they go back and forth between
refugees and Veterans trying to find the
sweet spot so the company moles and
Company LLC is a publicly traded
multinational investment firm so there's
is very likely Black Rock State Street
and Vanguard are involved well we got we
got to check we got to check 20 minutes
yeah we should we should check no Enjoy
your black rock beverage whatever you
they they don't put money in everything
smooth Taste of Black Rock
I can wait wait let me try that's a good
name for a
drink it tastes like a young Millennial
couple losing a bit on their first yeah
yeah but let's let I'll look into it
while my tastes like foreclosure that's
my favorite flavor
yeah that's so fun so anyway cool hip
beverage his own by maybe what about
what about liquid we got liquid death
over here too are they I hear they're
they're they are based AF perhaps I
don't know yeah I think so I think
they're pretty yeah I don't think
they've gone public yet I think they're
talking about going public but uh I
don't think they have you guys want to
know a secret I heard the liquid death
was partially own by the Clinton
Foundation you guys want to know a
secret yeah every so liquid death is you
pour them out and just put top water in
it give it to your guess it says no no
it says death of plastic on those cans
yeah look I like liquid death but
there's plastic in those cans okay
plastic and cans all cans are line with
oh they lining so if you take what
everyone used to say to Pamela Anderson
there's plastic in those
cans nice but if if you if you uh uh
take something that will eat away the
metal leaves a plastic bag yeah and and
you'll see the drink in the plastic bag
and you can oh the the coating yeah the
whole inside is coated so we actually
did it my brother did skin from the
lizard people that's how that's that's
how they make your Cann beever actually
this is disconcerting the sixth
ingredient on here is adrenochrome so
nice no liquid do actually pretty good
yeah it's also like fairly based low
sugar I like yeah it's also like when
the reason you about to have Plastics
when it's in the Sun so keeping out of
the sun supposedly negates it that's
what I've heard I don't know if that's
true or not let's jump story let's jump
to this one we got this from Bloomberg
yako the pizza gate Pizzeria oh no no no
let's talk about this story yakin's memo
to ex-staff calls musk candid and
profound I love this uh long story short
the CEO has doubled down when they
announced that Linda Yaro was going to
be the CEO everybody thought okay here
we go WF you know deep State whatever
she's going to start Banning people
instead when Elon Musk says go off
yourself she puts out a statement being
like no we stand by this and we believe
in it and we will not be bullied to
change our position because people are
trying to hold money from take money
from us here's the best part I see these
lefties on Twitter mocking her for doing
this being like haha look at her she's
pushing this this interview out more and
I'm like I think that's a great test to
expose who the grifters are because
these leftists who are saying that what
they're telling us is that in their
worldview they're saying why why would
you want to lose money whereas Elon is
saying take all the money from me I'm
not backing down from what I believe is
right so it shows you where we are where
they are not everybody on the left I'm
just saying the ones that are saying
that you're saying the sort of this
sentiment is like well you're screwing
your career but without any talk of do
they actually think that yeah so when
when I see these lefties be like haha
why would you why would you push this
further you know they're basically
saying why would you announce an
ideological position that would
jeopardize your business and it's really
funny because to me I'm on the other
side I'm like I absolutely will tell an
Advertiser to screw off if they tried to
do that I think Elon Musk doesn't do
anything unless he sees a long-term gain
right so he wouldn't announce these
positions publicly if he didn't think
that they were worth it and I think
that's the the measure that culture is
Shifting I mean even with Yaro the thing
that she got in trouble for was that she
was saying Twitter we like Free Speech
but we will de amplify hateful content
and de amplify was like a specific word
about you know people get afraid of like
being Shadow banned or whatever and to
for her to have fallen in line with a
more musk esque position is interesting
shifts within the company he's the boss
but I don't think elon's playing 5D
chess I think he's just pissed and he's
the richest man in the world so he can
tell anybody who wants to f off in the
world why does he care about this I mean
he could stay quiet and spend his money
on who cares think come out unless there
was a specific gain for absolutely
disagree my point is Elon Musk clearly
cares more about his ideological
position than the money whereas also
cares about Legacy his own yeah I
completely agree and so his position is
Free Speech matters the woke mind virus
is destructive and I'm not going to
sacrifice the world for a paycheck
especially it's easy to say when the
richest guy on the planet but I don't
think it has to be a paycheck right like
what is his longterm this has gained him
so much influence among conservative or
moderate people like he could have been
a silent billionaire just doing whatever
he wanted with his cars and his a
million children he was never a silent
billionaire though he was loud and proud
but he he could have been if he wanted
to he has chosen to continue to push
down this past because he wants to be in
the public eye that's not an ideological
position there might be a counter to
that though like with Tesla he was able
to sell it because he was not a you know
silent person it was the first time it
worked for him but that wouldn't existed
if he wasn't loud because he was loud
and got everyone to invest in him I know
he knows that having social influence is
really important it is the ultimate
social currency right now in which case
he should have said I'm sorry to the
advertisers because then this unless he
doesn't think it's long unless the
ideological position is more important
to him yeah he's consistent Elon clearly
is a guy who cares about ideological
issues yeah my point is that I think he
realizes the issues that he's promoting
right now and maybe he him personally I
have no reason to doubt his authenticity
he realizes that it resonates with the
American public in a way the
international public people feel like
yeah they are being manipulated by big
corporations that don't represent their
values and then you have this guy saying
I'm going to be open and speak out about
this but that's not a financial
incentive I never said might a longterm
Financial incentive yeah well it's it's
I I I just I think it's ideological
there there's there's no I look the way
he said go f yourself it's clearly an
emotional reaction oh yeah especially
when he said he's like you know if if x
ceases to be a company then you see that
thing we said he like if if you know if
they break us and ruin us then at least
people will know who did it like he said
it in this really weird way we you're
like but if it wasn't if it was planned
I'm not saying it was does that make it
less authentic like if he had gone on
there being like I know I'm going to
find a way to just say go f yourself to
the advertisers when to go on this thing
I do sort of agree with Tim that he does
fly by the seat of his pants for sure
big time seems at least seems like it
one thing you can say though about
platforms where you could say oh who
cares they can just get any
advertisement that is the sign that a
platform is sort of you go this is sort
of an off the beaten path platform as
you start seeing dick enlargement pills
and like all that sort of stuff so if
you went on Twitter and it was all those
kind of advertisers it would take away
from its like legitimacy as a town but
it is a lot of chichin Chong have so
weird everybody says that I've never
seen that I am 90% honestly I seen
people say this all the time they go my
whole thing is chich and Chong and I've
all I see is is I see that doctor with
the gooey thing you see that one it has
like 200 million impressions must be
spending Millions what is he selling I
don't know I've been I click on the
website and it's like's honestly I think
he's just saying that it's good to use
like MCT oil or stuff I don't even what
you're talking about is that the one
where he says don't put cream in your
coffee yes and then I'm like and and
then I went on the website to try and
but like every one of their ads has
they're not 100 million impressions
they're spending so much money and I
specifically I'm like all right let's
see what this does just because I wanted
to know I couldn't even figure out what
this yeah I watched this video for like
10 minutes and I'm like okay well that
was a fun podcast I guess I don't prodct
yeah that was but I don't know okay cool
oh for the record I cannot confirm at
all that black rock has any money in
spin I can't anywhere it's been for
about 10 minutes yeah thanks but that
that guy was saying you're right he's
like he's like you want to have uh you
want to have uh no I think he was saying
MCT was bad wasn't he I don't know I I
can't figure it out no he said coconut
is good or maybe coconut I don't I don't
know but they don't to Coconut Lobby
just out there you about this it's like
some Doctor Who has just tons of money
but like I can't tell what he even sells
but they're spending so much money on I
think the problem they're going through
we went through this at mines is that
these investors come in with huge
amounts of money and they say I want x
amount of Impressions over this much
time and then they put it all the money
so it goes to the front and keeps
getting recycled and it's like really
bad for the the platform because you
don't want people to get saturated with
the same ad over and over yeah I guess
that's happening cuz you guys all see
the same ads and I see the same ads but
they're different I haven't seen either
one of these ads if that helps at all
Chong is out there man that guy's got
the deepest pocket in Hollywood what are
they advertising what is C
Gumm C gummies he's just advertising
getting high Alterna Lifestyles he's not
saying like any specific brand he
doesn't have a choice got to say though
uh he's just saying spark him up man
Instagram ads infinitely better than
than x I'm not trying to be a dick I
like X but I go on Instagram and it's
like they have they have shirts that you
would wear it's like pictures of me
wearing the shirts like you're wearing
the shirts dude they get me too
Instagram is pretty good at that you're
just like a shirt that you were just
imagining in your mind you think it's
cuz they have the shop feature now that
they were able to more seriously refine
their data yeah if you buy one thing get
they know what you like immediately they
might have deal with like they could
have deals like Zuckerberg's a
psychology he's did a Psychology major
in college I'm pretty sure they're
obsessed with tracking you and getting
all they're tracking you places all over
the interet and it shows in the ads
they're successful but like at what cost
well Facebook was like in their terms of
service if you opened Facebook on any
tab they could read every other tab you
had open even in different Windows which
is like Facebook it starts drizzling out
they're pitching you umbrellas like they
are on it yeah yo crazy story is that we
went to uh I went to a Walmart once this
is like five years ago and we were
walking down the middle of one of the
aisles and they had one of those things
set up in the middle of the aisle which
a bunch of TVs and it said special on
sale 397 TVs and I was like I didn't
think twice I was like oh okay you know
maybe we get one of these and then we we
we leave I go home sit down on my
computer and there's an ad for that
exact photo that happens a lot and I was
like on the sidebar and I was like wait
what like it wasn't just a photo at a
Walmart it may have been but it was
identical to the like the aisles were
the same I was like it may actually be
that Walmart has a crew member take a
photo or they hear your words that's the
other part like God they just say it and
I'll see penis reduction pills and I was
just talking about probably the GPS on
the phone yeah and it's possible I don't
know if they do this but imagine it's a
very smart to do Walmart says hey this
morning team leag take a picture of your
TVs because we're doing an ad campaign
they go okay and then take a picture
upload it and then the Walmart team on
Facebook has Regional advertisements
with those photos so when my phone
aligns with the GPS Facebook serves me
the ad for that region at that Walmart
of the photo of the exact TVs I was
looking at in marketing they want to
show you the same ad eight times to get
you to buy it there's a number eight I
think it's eight could be a different
number at this point and so what they'll
do probably is they're tracking what ads
are what stores and if you go to that
store by GPS then they want to serve you
that ad again and get you to buy that
thing yeah in CID I mean you call it ins
cidus it's really dirty if people don't
know what's happening to them bro it's
it's crazy how I mean yo you you guys
want toar something crazy yeah so when
we went and got the ninth time they
showed you that thong yeah I just had to
buy it I was like I was like I can't
stop I hit the button and it is true no
uh uh so we went to I went to Tiana to
get medical treatment because I was
having hip problems and so we did this
whole thing at the uh uh cellular
performance Institute got stem cells and
they said one of the things you can't do
is you can't do ice ice uh uh uh uh what
what are they called ice baths or
whatever yeah is that what it's called
you can't for three months because it
kills the stem cells for three months
and no saunas take it easy start
exercising slowly and I'm like okay cool
no problem how are you going to f life
but yo as soon as the three months were
up guess what Instagram sent me an ad
for an ice bath oh no like like exactly
at the 3 month Mark not exactly like
with like a week of it and I'm like wait
fory I I've never done this stuff I've
never done an ice bath I've never done
any of that ice skate and all of a
sudden I'm getting ads for it and I'm
like I didn't even Google search
this I bought one yeah yeah yeah I B I
bought it it's automatic it chills the
water you go on your phone you press the
button it chills the water and spinning
it around and then once you're done
working out you dive in and I ended up
buying it you got an ice bath it's on
its way oh nice they got me I don't know
stand dude they got meub J I don't know
man maybe it's you know what it is it's
probably not as crazy as you think I
follow Joe Rogan for and like you follow
probably so many like and they're like
everybody who follows these guys has
heard about this and they're probably
going to buy it if we send it to them
it's that simple and Luke goes n one his
house they're also putting you an upper
eant of money they're not sending
everyone like here buy this $5,000 ice
bath that's getting served to very few
people it could hot tub and ice bath
it's got a pump that you you can like
with an app set the temperature you know
what you're on you're on the sucker list
oh yeah they're like the whale category
like these Mor will spend anything
definitely they got me though change our
lives man that UFO that's crazy that was
that that was that levitating UFO right
there are all these knickknack that
you bought that just you got that I
can't stop I need help you did get a
bunch of like swords or something right
there was like a I don't remember
remember being like I got this Instagram
ad and now I have it you're the
grandmother buying the 911 coins well I
got a bunch of those what do you
mean no I don't have any of those I do
have a bunch of trump coins signature
Trump coins and they have like the
American flag on the back no I have the
Canadian ones I like the Maple Leaves
really oh the actual gold the gold like
one no not Gold Silver and I always get
the Canadian ones because there's
something just awfully cute about a
country being like look at our Maple
Leaf you know it's like it's the most
inoffensive and and like that's how we
get you man that's buy our silver that's
right they were just talking about
trying to unload some silver on suckers
Canadian but had a bad batch of silver
then you done load but I'm imagining
it's like you know a bunch of gangs are
showing up to like the street fight and
one guy's like I got a Falon another
guy's like I have a spear and then
Kenna's like we've got some Maple leaes
and I'm like what are you doing I love
it and it blinds them and then what well
that's kind of we haven't thought of the
Resto no what people don't get is that
as soon as the fight starts they they
drop the maple leaf and they're holding
maple syrup and they throw it in your
eyes and you're like yeah it's just
extra thick stuff that's where it all
maple syrup in the eyes there bud hold
on this is true there Maple Taffy do you
guys yeah of course yeah so so there's a
bunch of things you do I went to a maple
farm recently so I learned nice if you
if you dry out the maple syrup a lot you
get a paste you get like a goo like
taffy and it's like sticky and yeah it's
a big thing you go to the Sugar Bush and
then they tap the trees or whatever and
then they like put it on the snow that's
right eat it off the snow it's a
Canadian
tradition delicacy let's jum this you
ever did let's jump to this story we
have a tweet from Patrick Bet David it's
it's a Redemption Arc for Chris Cuomo
Patrick B David tweets Chris Cuomo
trending for being open to the idea of
voting for Trump people are losing their
minds over this and he is certainly
correct let's play the clip it's a it's
about two minutes long we'll just we'll
play a little bit of it it's if it's
Biden Trump look for me again um we
survived a trump
Administration uh would we survive
another one yes yes I don't think
there's any greater risk To America with
him than with Biden and for people who
are now going to
attack me and say what are you talking
about Trump is like this crazy man well
look you know as Patrick says the data
is the data nobody was trying to kill us
when Trump was president in a way that
they're not now if anything there's more
hostility and you can have reasons for
that any way you want I'm just saying
existentially I'm not afraid of a trump
presidency um existentially I'm not
afraid of another Biden presidency
because unlike many people in America I
believe that the country is much
stronger than any individual leader um
we survived the Russia thing we survived
January 6th we survived having Biden as
a gaff machine we survived uh Congress
uh going after each other and doing
nothing for the rest of us we survive
these things are we better for it no uh
should we be doing things differently
yes
I think it happens I don't know when I
don't even know why but you know in
terms of who I'm going to vote for I
would really have to see where we are at
that moment in
time uh and so you're open to Trump vote
I am always open and I'll tell you this
people say oh you've never
voted for a republican in your life
wrong and not only we get it we get it
he's trying his Redemption Arc at first
I was afraid he just breaks into the qu
music that's the official death of the
cuomosexual tattoo right there anybody
who has one they're getting they watch
us go all right I was on the fence but
I'm getting that thing lasered off all
those all those shirts I kind of want to
buy one now you know like LeBron when he
like went to the Heat and everybody's
burning their homosexual shirts
homosexual that stinks for you
homosexual right now like you you
suffered through Andrew now Chris is
forsaking you yeah was what is it Chris
Andrew wants to be Governor again or
something oh go I think he may wants
mayor of New York City you guys you guys
are still in New York right yeah is is
it because you have something wrong with
you they all no New York no those guys
all kind of like they get they don't
they lose one election and by the end of
it they're just like campaigning to be
like a condo board president just
there's like I need
some position the library board yeah
what do you guys what do you guys think
New York New York's one of the sickest
cities in the world you're right it is
sick it's awful you think Chris Cuomo is
just trying to he's trying to find his
Redemption Arc he's already been doing
that no he $10 million a year at CNN I'm
sure he's trying to like some sort of
paycheck he's and he's also like
podcasting now he realizes this you know
his just like whatever the mainstream
thinks I think is not going to work
anymore so he's trying to show that he
has Nuance no no no no no it's it's
quite the opposite he's the whatever the
mainstream thinks I will say when he
that's what he was no no no and now that
he's going into the podcast space when
he's actually dealing with real people
it's the independent voter base is 2 to
one Trump over over Biden so all he's
doing is adapting to the environment
he's in now he's doing the exact same
that's what I just said no one ever
challeng CNN but but my I'm saying if he
was still at CNN he wouldn't be saying
this that's point I agree I agree my
point was simply the podcast world is
the mainstream and he's simply doing the
same thing he's he's just Towing the
line for whatever the popular narrative
is I would even say it's maybe less so
just mainstream not mainstream it's like
if you're going to be doing these
three-hour interviews with all different
sorts of people you have to sort of show
that you have some nuance and he wants
people to see him as a reasonable guy
and listen to his podcast that's that's
how I see it people have asked me if I
would have him on and I'm like yeah I'd
love to the first question is why did
you fake being in quarantine yeah that's
when you watch that video him coming up
out of his basement be like oh I never
left the house and then people are like
but we saw him outside but and his son
is watching him lie and just his son's
face is just so's so much disrespect
lying to kids right nowy this guy this
guy this guy will never come on this
show that you can listen listen Cuomo
will never come on this show he will
because the first question is why did
you fake being in now you said got tons
of time and then I'm absolutely going to
say and the second question is do you
think your children are worse off for
having watched you lie on television
that way no I think they're better well
that's a good question but I think that
his kid might be a big part of the
reason why he's not doing I get I get
people saying oh Tim when you insult
these people now they won't come on your
show I'm like oh like okay too bad what
this dude did was contributing to
psychotic
authoritarian author just government f
ISC Nazi garbage I think people are
breaking out of the Empire like they're
shattering their allegiance to the
Empire and by that I mean like the dark
Empire of Star Wars and they're coming
too and they're they're definitely
willing to be like yo maybe this
Rebellion ain't so I just think he go
back I think CNN could offer him in a
second he's from a political like huge
political family like he in his mind
he's like yeah you lie because it's for
the greater good he's in New York that's
like where all of his connections are
they're all but probably still attached
to CNN like it's not only his like Life
religion and Social Circle it's how he
values himself so he might do this right
now but if CNN was like we'll cut you
like a quarter of the check we gave you
he'd be like okay sounds I think he
would go back and be the weatherman if
they that check if if if he really did
want to come on the show knowing I will
ask him all these questions that would I
would I would respect that 100% yeah I
mean I think if he's going I haven't
seen the whole Patrick B David but if he
went on there for three hours I can't
imagine he was getting Patrick B David
does not do the kid gloves treatment
agreed agreed yeah and that's kind of
wild to me because I feel like Patrick B
David actually goes harder than than I
do he does like when when he brought out
the boots for Ronda santis like wow dude
like Patrick B David is awesome that was
amazing I would never do that like I
don't know if I have the balls to pull
out a pair of boots and be like put them
on Ron you know what I mean take your to
gifts I can't gifts I'm willing to ask
the question but I don't I don't know
about actually like put them on Patrick
is like all right we're going back to
back shoes off right
now competition let's settle this yeah
he's big awesome he's real big and
muscular got that Vibe like I'm a
soldier he was Soldier yeah dude yeah
great great show by the way and man yeah
you've been on his show several times
it's amazing he's he's a good dude and I
really respect and appreciate how he he
brings his people on bringing on weer
bringing on Cuomo that was a great
episode weer did you guys see call break
no freebies no freebies he he calls him
out so I respect it I tend to think like
I'm My Own Worst Enemy and that if I do
talk crap about people before I even
give them a chance that I'm ruining my
own pathway my own career so I I air on
the side of May maybe Chris is down to
jam man let's let's talk about the weird
stuff let's talk about what life was
like at CNN and make a better career
he'd be an interesting guest to talk
about like what was life at CNN because
obviously we have a lot of strong
opinions about it and the mainstream
media generally but I I think it would
be you know it would be unlikely that he
would come on again because I think so
much of it is tied to I eventually want
to end up back in the hive yeah it is
possible though it's the other way where
he actually hated what his job was for
the last four years where it was like
here's what you got to do got paid
it is possible that like behind closed
doors he was going home and he's like I
got to say this freaking garbage at work
like he might have not liked that that
would have been cool and if he could
come on and tell us that I would like it
a lot yeah I accept that like we we we
talk about budlight and how we want to
be mad at budlight for sponsoring Dylan
milany but now that they're sponsoring
UFC you know credit to Shan Strickland
who pointed out they're now backing the
opinions of all these MMA fighters who
are based now it's kind of like okay I I
think we got to give Bud Light a little
bit because we don't get the apology we
want but them back UFC they're going to
be putting money behind the words of all
these MMA fighters that's like a big
victory yeah I was sort of saying this
uh even before we started but I'm fairly
forgiving person uh for that kind of
stuff like I I don't hold the opinion
that if someone uh screwed up or said
something I don't like or whatever you
know that forever you're just like that
guy's off limits you got to give him a
path to Redemption so if we say to Bud
Light no matter what you do we will
never buy your product then they're
going to say okay well at least we can
capture a small Market if we go back the
other direction towards the left if we
say you know what bud like you sponsored
UFC so we're actually going to start
buying again then they're going to be
like sponsor more of this stuff and that
means they're going to put more money
into people we do like and opinions we
do like I guess you're talking about the
actual basis of uh you know voting with
your dollars exactly so we want these
companies to sponsor things we like and
stop doing things we don't like so when
Disney makes a whole bunch of weird woke
movies and they fail we don't got to do
anything we just don't have to watch
their crap because we don't like it they
they get the message and they put out to
their investors like Hey we're doing
something wrong and so with Bud Light
could you does that mean that you would
only buy Bud Light at like a UFC event
because if I assume they separate their
grocery sales right I will buy budlight
the next time we get a UFC fighter with
the budlight symbol and he says
something and then budlight just accepts
it because what I'm worried about is
Shan Strickland will come out at the
press conference for like a championship
fight or or whenever he's fighting next
and he's going to say here are my
thoughts on politics xyzabc and then
budlight goes we do not support these
opinions and we reject this then I'm
going to be like okay that's the test if
the guy says it and people go budlight
why are you sponsoring this and budlight
ignores it I'll buy budlight yeah I
think they will I think they probably
decided that they know this is going to
happen and probably that's the
rehabilitation is by saying like yep we
we sponsor the UFC that's we we don't
sponsor the individuals we're just here
for UFC the fighters can say what they
want I'll be like I'll take it I mean
you hope they would have learned their
lesson yeah you might call it an AB test
get it anheiser Bush it's such a lame
joke you you made a good point a while
ago you said that you lost the
confidence I
said Ian I made a point a while ago that
that sometimes you'll work with evil
people to do good and and he's
completely correct the motivations of
the anheiser bush people may be
absolutely nefarious in fact let's let's
let's bring it back to Cuomo Cuomo may
be a lying manipulative piece of garbage
who is going on pbd and trying to lie to
people to win favor and you know what
doesn't mean I trust him but when he's
saying he's open to voting for Trump and
now there's a lot of people who are
going to be like you know what I'm
willing to listen now you think he saw
Rapaport getting all the press for it
and he's like I can I can getting some
news stories here he may be an evil guy
but if what he's doing contributes to
good I'm not going to condemn him for
doing something that's beneficial good
people have a lot of people have been
roped up in this system this corporate
fascist system and it's understandable
there's a lot of money you get famous
you can s give your kids good healthy
food they can grow up smart but you know
it is nice to see people cracking out of
it yeah I don't know if I trust him but
I think he said something good so okay
all right take it you know even if it's
just open open to it this this what we
see with like him and rap aore awesome I
bet you you well I just bet you a guy
like him it's like you break down all
this stuff he's not crazy ideologically
I bet this is just a guy I think it's
good for his like fans to see him say
this stuff because people who thought he
was you know the people Good Die hards
are probably no he's giving out yeah
he's giving him an out so now these
people are going to be like well you
know I was listening to comoo he made a
really good point so now I think I kind
of get it it's like as long as there is
someone in the mainstream who's who's
prominent and well off saying it people
will feel safe to be like oh don't look
at me I mean Chris Cuomo is the guy I
mean I'm just some dude who listens to
the news he's the one who said it
they're feeling like it's safe now to
come out and say these things yeah so so
I'll take it right yeah there's there's
a lot of people that have come out in
the last two years have been like bring
back Trump I mean all of the the
Palestine stuff turned everyone against
Biden wild dude they they went to the
Rockefeller Christmas tree lighting and
they were chanting burn it down yeah
it's like dude you don't take Christmas
away from people like the conservatives
went nuts over the war on Christmas they
were angry over happy holidays you want
to send a bunch of people screaming burn
it down to a giant Christmas tree and it
caught on fire last year so it's too
soon that's true that's your point if
you want to say a good thing about about
New York though because you're saying
New York's so crappy but the good thing
is sometimes you be on Twitter and you
be like oh they're like rioting and it's
like two blocks away you can just go
check it
out that's a good thing yeah it's fun
this Topsy tury world right now you're
about to see sha King in a mega hat
standing outside top of the at the top
climbing the Christmas tree so with the
with the Israel Palestine stuff yeah
it's getting weird buddy I saw Jonathan
greenblat doing an interview he was
calling people
snowflakes like well you've got Media
Matters attacking the Anti-Defamation
League because the ADL was like ah
elon's all right because he's Banning
from The River To The Sea and then Media
Matters is like Israel is bad how dare
you ADL what are you doing and I'm like
Media Matters in the Anti-Defamation
League are are like at odds with each
other right now wild love to see it love
it love it cancel each other and just
most disappear no Jonathan gria he was
literally being like kids are too
sensitive right now they dude he was
like doing a bill Mah monologue it was
crazy let's jump to this story we got
this from Business Insider Trump who's
railed against black lives matter for
years now says he'd be very honored to
have its support that's actually phrased
rather poorly he actually said thank you
for your support and so basically you
got this uh former BLM black lives
matter leader who said the Democratic
party is not for us he says uh he's for
we got this guy Fisher introduced by Fox
as a co-founder of black lives matter
Rhode Island said personally I love the
man I mean how could you not like a real
man how could you not relate to someone
like that Trump then wrote out truth
social that he had spoken with fiser he
called a great guy say very honored to
have his and blm's support uh Trump said
before claiming to have done more for
black people than any other president
Lincoln and off disputed remark he's Reg
regly made in the last few years now
we've got um let let me see if I have
this one is from uh Matt Walsh where we
go uh here we go Matt Walsh took the
Trump BLM situ uh took the Trump BLM
situ situation in no situation should
Trump be thanking a Marxist terrorist
organization if Des stist thanked BLM
Trump fans would never stop talking
about it ever says when honest people
hear Republican thanking BLM they should
be asking questions about what the
person really stands for completely
disagree Trump is smart it was the smart
play Black lives matter did not endorse
Trump Trump is trying to make people
think they did because he's trying to PR
manipulate people yeah he's start of
saying black guys love me yeah exactly
it's also sort of misleading in general
you know how there's the bunch of the
different libertarian parties and then
there's a couple of them that're just
like super W like say way Wilder stuff
and then people always kind of uh you
know they'll they they'll be like oh the
libertarian part's out of control but
it'll be like a small part of it this is
the same thing this is the one BLM
chapter saying they like Trump the other
one's posting hand but it's one guy it's
one yeah gu they're posting the yeah
like they're they're very that's what I
mean they have a million different
chapters Trump knows the media this is
how he gets it because what's going to
happen is some Suburban wife is going to
be sitting with the other wine moms and
one's going to go did you hear Black
lives matter endorsed Trump what was
that like that means we endorse Trump
well it's going to open the door for
people to be like I guess Trump's not
that bad well they have their Shelf with
like BLM and like a trump with his face
crossed out and they're just like huh
just puts it's in a bit of a bond and to
Matt Walsh's point that if DeSantis
thanked BLM he'd get roasted maybe but I
don't think by most people and this
shows exactly why DeSantis has been
struggling with it because dantis
doesn't understand the disantis campaign
doesn't get people Donald Trump thanking
BLM I'm like wow Trump's winning if
Ronda santis did the same thing like
someone from BLM endorsed Ronda santis
and he said thank you I'd be like very
good very very good of him to embrace
those who are supporting him the fact
that they they view it that way explains
exactly why the campaign has been slight
yeah I think there's a part of it is the
to break an to make an omelet you got to
break a few eggs and in this case Matt
Walsh being mad at use the egg you know
what I mean
and santis would be afraid to break any
of those eggs yeah s is done though
right santis is not going to amfest and
so uh this was something uh uh Jack was
talking about this last night right
pretty sure man I wonder that they they
they was a conversation and it ended
yeah they invited him and then he's like
I'm not going to come and it's like
you're trying to win a primary why
aren't you coming to this massive event
with all of these people I mean Tucker
Carlson's going to be there like
basically everybody's going to be there
it's an opportunity if he showed up we'd
all shake his hand and be like we we
you're the best governor in the country
we love your work instead he's like I'm
not going to do it it's wild I got to
prepare for my debate with some guy
that's not even running yep crazy got a
session with my cobbler those things are
WR well uh apparently the rumor is he
bought inserts he bought when he's like
they're they're they're off the off the
rack liesi boots yes and so were your
inserts off the rack from you know from
some other store you jammed them in
there but dude come on the guy's wearing
high heels man yeah it's crazy there're
maybe that's why he can't go to mfest
cuz Charlie Kirk is like also 100 feet
tall and so if he stands next to him
it'll look kind of off if he went to the
CRA live like that though you can't just
live like that for the rest of Tom Cruz
and Vin Diesel and Mark walber man I
guess but they're only I guess a picture
of that guy beside Nick Cage where he's
not in an Apple box that's why I think
the Sanders won't come on this show
because isir tall I'm 5'9 like he could
yeah but pbd is tall and he he actually
pulled the boots and slammed them on the
desk the president he goes hey we need
like a 15 16 scale Oval Office we just
need to make it slightly small put the
panel on the front of the desk in the OV
office to hide the wheelchair so it's
not the craziest thing we've ever done
oh that's when they added the panel mhm
to hide the wheelchair my well but the
but cuz if you look at pictures of
Kennedy there's like there's a famous
picture of um his son playing under the
desk you can see it but then the panel
but that's because that's actually a
different desk the original desk it has
that secret compartment with the with
the the writing in it oh yeah so you can
track down the the Declaration of
Independence or the treasure or whatever
what was the treasure in that movie
anyway I never saw it talking about
American National Treasure National talk
about like the greatest movie series of
all time oh that first one was you know
what if we can convince Ron three of
them if we can convince Ron to go to
amfest and do a skit about the boots
that's really funny and then he'll just
be a rockar that's it no he can't
because way that might go not the way he
thinks D you guys all saw my boot sketch
and everyone's he can't do it because
the boots are real if are you sure
though oh come on dude but the Wikipedia
says he's anywhere from 55 to 5'11 I
heard he's on actual stilts in
interview another person Len there a
smaller Ronda santz there's that video
of him on stage where you can clearly
see his foot the front of the shoe is
bent up there's no foot in there yeah so
come on like there there are there are
way too many news stories breaking down
various photos and they actually even
talked to cobblers who are like oh yeah
he those are lifts no question he's 5'8
C come the Cobblers have never been
interviewed this much in their lives
dude he was walking home from the club
holding them in his hand but so the
point is if it was not true he could do
a sketch and it would be hilarious he'd
show up and then he he he'd choke with
the boots on it wouldn't be a sensitive
issue well guess the make or break
moment I'm assuming it's he would be
exposing that he's wearing high heels if
he does the skit okay he did really sign
him up to wear those high heels for the
rest of his life you're like die those
undo those be incredible though if he
debates Trump and then Trump shows up in
his own heels just to further it yes you
really are small huh well right so you
know the point of the heels is basically
to to make him appear taller against
other candidates so if Trump wore like
4in lifts yeah just and make him look
really short and be like I'm wearing the
same boots as Ronnie over here little
Ron they call him I've gotten so much
content on of Ron s's Li whoever put him
in those lips it was the worst move they
ever made I could not have this would be
one of the major political talking
points going into this I could come on
no even car I had no idea how the Howard
Dean woohoo there's a whole bunch of
wacky political moments you couldn't
have predicted the lifts I mean come on
that's I know I'm saying the fact that
there's a weird moment where some can
did something goofy that's like that's
that's what happens like Mitt Romney and
the dog or whatever I mean we talked
about Trump's hand size for four years
so yeah that's point they things do get
overanalyzed that's so weird like his
hands they made up that thing about his
hands it's just like does that work for
people who don't like Trump they did it
for Napoleon they said he was short the
different
measurements because the Imperial guards
are tall and so people would often
compare him in in in paintings to tall
Imperial guards but oh he must have been
short and he wasn't and now we talk
about King Charles hands right like the
English those are crazy hands those are
something going on there yeah those are
weird Sasha's hands I just I get small
places on the island someone someone
comes to me and they're like uh Donald
Trump wants to fire a bunch of people he
wants to secure our borders bring back
manufacturing and Foreign Wars and I'm
like oh okay and then the left goes
drump you mean with little hands and I'm
like I I I don't understand like is that
an argument am I I don't get it it was
to them that was very clever those like
plastic little hands that people used to
wear I used to see those on Tik Tok all
the time like the T yeah did did he
accidentally make something cool by
himself does it turn out he has just big
hands or normal hands or something he
probably has normal hands and someone
took shot at his hands and then he gets
super defensive about stuff like he'll
so he goes I got normal hands totally
like and then he makes whole thing I
don't know and then the most normal and
probably was like did a couple sketches
about the hands and then I don't know
just the hands become a thing I just no
one's talking about the hands now with
the boots and in the equation guys in a
few minutes the debate with desandis and
Newsome is going to start and I just I
honestly I cannot care you know I I I
part of me is like there's this news
thing happening and like maybe we should
check it out and I'm just like pants
leftt
but nothing matters the only that
matters is something about the boots the
reality is oh do you think do you think
that they're not going to push uh Gavin
Nome to become the nominee I think they
are so that's what this is is like take
a look at yeah yeah like just like
seeing how he plls against the S this is
like they're both down they're crouched
they're about The Gunshot has gone off
and then they just take off running and
this is it this is the moment when the
run just starts and this is airing on
Fox only I don't I guess so cuz it's um
Sean Spicer's show and then he just
agreed to host SE Spicer has a show on
Fox they're trying to appeal no Hannity
so they're trying to appeal Nome to the
right wing now they want the
conservatives to see a good
gas honestly you if you uh if you find
yourself listening to Newsome he can
convince people of things man he is a
good speaker so what's going to happen
cuz Biden doesn't want to before you
listen to new for an hour you're like
maybe California is crushing
it as you're as you're walking on the
street stepping you got human crap all
over your life we got to watch it cuz
the way that California and Florida
handled Co is so diametrically opposed
who even cares about that anymore I know
I'm just I'm i n look there's like World
War 3's about to
break no it's it's like it's like two
guys are going to debate whether or not
you should mow your lawn I'm like okay I
I don't know I I'll tell you why we
should watch it because our our
Consciousness is affecting reality in
real time it's like when you watch a
basketball game your perception is
altering those players and we can alter
that debate I don't I don't think so oh
you can I watched the Cavs come back
from a 3-1 deficit and win the
championship
videos on YouTube of me of me willing it
it's real yeah don't you think there was
someone else willing the Golden State
not as powerful as me apparently I was
willing LeBron like he's from my
hometown akan oh you're from akan yeah
kaga Falls and uh there I I I shouted
his name in a video and it echoed
through the room in this Wild Way well
that proves it okay there's some deep
manifestation going on and then they
just picked it up I I bet there was some
guy who had like uh you know 20 G's on
the Cavs who was manifesting it way more
than you were but listen the only
the only the only one who benefits from
this debate is Nome I don't care to to
benefit Nome they're trying to swap him
in they want to replace Biden with Nome
so Nome should not get any any uh
credits in any way happens he's
irrelevant he doesn't matter and I don't
care what happens if Biden won't step
down do the does the DNC just like go
behind Biden's back at the last minute
and say it's Nome yep yeah it's too late
for Nome to get on any primaries several
of the primaries which means he can't
win unless the DNC just hereby decrees
and they can they can say no we're
making this in the nominee regardless
there's no primary process have a nice
day so what we don't want this debate
with with Dan santis this is this is why
I think are they literally allowed to
force him out it's a private
organization they can do whatever they
want the DNC gets to pick the cand D is
private it's insane yeah they they
choose but it's it's not insane it's
like weird even as an incumbent though I
mean yes so so ask me this question can
Tim C fire whoever can I fire whoever I
want yeah yes can you fire someone right
now yes can like will you no you
please stop talking be here theync a
private organization and be like can you
nominate whoever you want well of course
we your votes don't matter yeah but the
RNC can't correct no they yeah the RC is
a private organization too I thought for
some reason in like 2016 the the the the
Bernie was the favorite but the DNC was
like yeah but we're making Hillary the
nominee but the for whatever reason the
Republicans couldn't do that to Trump
it's because they're trying to have some
semblance of you're involved because if
they if they just outright say no to the
people then everyone knows that there's
no real elections so actually the
Democrats wanted Trump to be the nominee
the Republicans were like I think we're
going to lose this one anyway so what
can we do and then Trump won but now
look at what they're trying to do
they're like the entire establishment is
trying to get Trump out the fact that
they went behind Biden get Biden out no
Trump they're trying to get Trump out
that's why Dan santis is debating Nome
it's giving legitimacy to Nome it is
absolutely the stupidest thing in the
world that these guys would be debating
even all the corporate press are like
it's a very unusual event to happen it's
not working whatever they're trying to
do no it's not no it's very bizarre I
can't tell from the chat if anyone even
cares let me let me say this my my
conspiracy theory and and Jack was
saying something similar a trump Dan
santis ticket would would have been
unbeatable yep until DeSantis decided to
lead the Great American comeback and put
on high heels won't let you down put on
high heels sent his surrogates to attack
all of the moderate base and Trump
supporters sabotaging whatever career
desus could have had and now Trump's
going for Ben kind of was a guy that
doesn't understand the internet that
much trying to run like a crazy internet
smear campaign campign or it was a guy
who knew it really well and said we're
going to syn to santis and make sure he
can never win again oh you're saying
it's the other way around where this was
a smear job on him well Ronda santis was
in 2022 he was leading Trump two to one
all of a sudden now Des santz is an
afterthought who's mocked and and a guy
who was known for wearing high heels how
do you go from being the best governor
in America who is the the front runner
for the GOP to all of a sudden being
laughed at I think some of it's the
culture changed in a way that didn't
favor his sensibilities which is just
kind of looking at Twitter for what
people want to want to hear as opposed
to having like a vision for what's next
perhaps but he could
have not engaged in like his surrogates
could have perhaps not attacked people
on Twitter like he could have fired them
the moment they did but that's that's
the part where I'm saying this is a guy
that doesn't understand internet culture
that's fair fair point yeah no no matter
how many times he has you got the
advisor I mean you have the advisers
being like no trust me this is what we
do and he's like okay yeah there's
something very like American like almost
like rocky-esque about Trump kind of
having his next shot like he's got this
rubber match right now to kind of yeah
you know last chance to basically be
president a way of like don't get it
wrong or versus get it right and Trump's
a get it right kind of guy whereas Dan
santis is being concerned about getting
it wrong it seems like it feels like
he's like doesn't want to make a mistake
whereas Trump's like I'm just going to
do the right thing old school politics
almost yeah yeah let's craft a narrative
but the internet so people thought for a
minute they go ah it's nice and peaceful
that like Trump's gone he's not like
taking up all this bandwidth and then I
think people were like nah we kind of
missed that actually I I want to clarify
someone super ched when when Ian said
the D the Democrats can just choose and
Republicans can't what that refers to is
a technicality Democrats have super
delegates who are appointed and can just
vote and Republicans don't but
ultimately these are private
organizations that choose how they run
and who vot who runs and how they do it
and they could just do whatever whatever
they but once they choose and
everything's in order the Democrats at
the very last second they they all you
can elect with the Democrats is not your
candidate you elect super delegates to
go pick the candidate for you be you
elect delegates super okay the delegates
elect the super no no no no go for it
there's delegates and superdelegates
when you vote you're electing delegates
superdelegates are people like Hillary
Clinton who just get to vote you're they
represent no one but themselves and can
they override the delegates that is so
well they don't override they vote for
what they want so if you vote in your
Democrat run thing your delegate goes
and says I'm going to vote for Bernie
and then Hillary walks out and goes N I
vote for me and it's like okay well
there you go your vote's been nullified
do the super delegates outnumber the
regular delegates I don't think so but
it but uh I'm not entirely sure but it
doesn't really matter because there's
enough superdelegates to overturn what
the the popular vote in the D so messed
up but the RNC doesn't have
superdelegates it's or the it's so crazy
that the DNC has superdelegates that
have like ultimate authority of choosing
the candate but it's because they're
Communists yeah it feels like that it's
so messed up like come on guy wait if
you're a Democrat and the Democratic
party you got to get rid of the superat
the fact probably set up so that you
just can't the fact that they're private
entities that can basically do whatever
they want is bad enough people don't
realize you don't have public elections
yeah I need to get rid of those aa aa he
coming on the show I know right let's
get him down that great he speak English
well I don't know we'll have to learn
Spanish not yet yeah he'll he'll be
learning it on the fast trck the next
two years so was he really yeah oh man
that guy's great this is his first trip
he made all all you need to do is send
me one video of him saying a fua and
ripping out government institutions and
I'm like I don't know anything about
this guy but he's awesome that's Javier
mle the president of Argentina
president-elect is he officially in now
or is he still the elect president-elect
he's still president-elect haven't had
the inauguration yet I'm so excited that
things like that things like guy inside
of Disney man the department of
women he that gives me hope that things
actually like this simulation is sorting
itself out that people like that get
into Power Department of Adam Sandler
movies okay we'll leave that one up
Department of diversity
AA he's like AA and then he slaps one up
and it's like Adam Sandler movies he's
getting two bureaucratic organizations
Adam Sandler is just what you say he has
like 10 Netflix movies or every year or
some ridiculous thing oh buddy he's
making films he just with one of his
kids too right like now he with the
whole mitz movie or something under the
radar you never see it you just go
you'll be like hey what were the 10
biggest movies you're like what's that
and you go Sandler film yeah yeah but
here's the thing about the 10 biggest
movies when we would talk about the 10
biggest Movies 20 years ago it's like oh
of course you know like oh Lord of the
Rings came out everybody knows that was
big oh Harry Potter now it's like one of
the 10 biggest movies you're Jack and
Jill n you're like Jack and Jill n and
it's like how many how many people
watched it 100,000 no no no it's more
like uh well it's more but you don't
know well 100 million I don't they
started figuring out streaming numbers
no Netflix still is that's a total black
box that the thing is can we get a fact
check on how many people watch Sandler
movies they might I think 20 million
people watch Big Bang Theory yeah Big
Bang Theory so so the the numbers Big
Bang Theory had back when it was on was
like 20 million on CVS I so I'm one I
don't buy it
yeah I mean if 80 how many people voted
for how many people voted for Joe Biden
84 million or something so here's here's
the thing 20 million people watch Big B
Theory I think right Joe fair but Joe
but here's the issue with Joe Biden Joe
Biden did not get 85 million votes yeah
85 million people voted against Donald
Trump sure 25% of that may maybe were
like I think Joe Biden's good for some
reason it probably exists but really
it's like people just saying I don't
like Trump the enthusiasm for Biden was
like 25% but the enthus enthusiasm
against Trump was like 96% I voted for s
or 8 times December 2023 December 1st
Adam 2023 Adam Sandler's movies have
grossed an estimated $2.4 billion at the
global box office but is that the
opposite
ofit is that of all time I think so
everybody
knows any box office money anymore
because I don't think the His Highest
grossest moving of all time is Hotel
Transylvania with the worldwide gross of
1.37 billion yes he made a movie he made
a deal at Netflix to make 85
movies but is Hotel Transylvania and
Adam Sandler movie or is it a movie he
stars in I think he's EP on it probably
is really probably like Happy Madison
but that's like that's an animated Kids
film yeah so of course he's making a lot
of money it's just kind of funny I would
like think about this like that he's
constantly making
like Adam Sandler is fantastic there's
no question I'm just saying I'm not even
saying that I'm just saying he's like
Loki in the shadows doing insane numbers
this is my point when in today's day and
age when we're talking about the biggest
shows the numbers are just that's
correct shattered it's it's especially
the ones that win all the awards like
you know you'll be like oh this was like
a big uh critics pick and it was like
150,000 viewers yeah right so when when
he makes a movie for Netflix and it's
like the top 10 movies on Netflix like
yeah but what did it get like 300,000
Netflix though are they pushing it to
the top like does Netflix have a
contract with them where they're like
you're going to make nine movies and
we're going to put all literally every
sing for sure yeah he has the CEO of
Netflix's kid hostage in his basement
and he says I'm no he doesn't he does
that's the thing it's like they actually
do on Netflix on the platform Netflix is
like this is we give him I think it's I
think he gets 20 million a movie or
something like 50 whatever he gets 20
million like after production cost but
like they do huge numbers on Netflix
where they go this is like a no break
cuz that's like a a cost that they're
paying him that they're not actually
paying him featuring his movie is like
that's no they prod no they're those are
Netflix exclusive movies they're not
anywhere else those are like the movies
that they make in house they signed a
deal with him just like Netflix has all
the Dave Chappelle specials and they
film them around his vacation schedule I
like for him to go hang out with the
boys and then they bring a he brings the
boys down to a new beach and does a
beach movie let me ask him questions all
right how many of you have seen
extraction to never heard of it I only
watched the first one nobody okay no how
many of you have seen pain hustlers
yeah I saw payers you did you really
think so you just saw it I saw this we
appar no I didn't see for one heard of
it how many of you have seen the deepest
breath no I literally haven't heard of
one of these okay nobody how about the
mother nobody okay let moving on how
about nowhere no all right a man called
a I've heard of that
that's no okay uh race the Su right to
the summit no nobody okay
plane how about Joan I don't Joanna man
okay uh so those are those are those are
the top 10 films based on uh uh uh this
uned says these are the top 10 films of
the of the year or whatever gosh best
but this is best not the most according
to viewers according to viewers ratings
though streaming next movie fans can
still get access some of the best
releases uh Facebook group rated these
my my my point is I know it's really I
can't fail with a Facebook but the thing
is Netflix does not divulge these
numbers like specifically right right
right so so often you'll see on on the
of Netflix it'll be like number six and
it'll be like top my point is there's a
Facebook fan group maybe it's not the
the the best metric we can check others
we didn't even hear Mothers Against D
Sandler it's not nobody even knows these
movies no no no none of them I mean the
biggest show on Netflix I'm pretty sure
is is Suits like cuz for whatever reason
they just started throwing up suits on
the front page of a show that hasn't
been on for a long time and then they
were like yeah it's done like you know
4,000 billion like minutes of watch time
or whatever ever and it just suddenly
became the big they're like buying
successful IP right and they're like
maybe they have the license for it and
then they're just cranking and then
people mean still people watch it they
do they're just like YouTube like they
want to keep on the platform let's try
this I'll tell you if any if any of
those films are getting huge numbers
then my Rumble numbers are real statista
says most popular English language
Netflix movies of all time as of October
2023 red notice heard of it haven't seen
it this makes more sense don't look up
saw it Adam project saw it Sandler movie
right there the Adam project men did not
see it week can be heroes no the mother
no Glass Onion saw it but I saw that in
theaters extraction extraction to I did
not see it so uh where's Halloween no
but this this this one actually makes a
bit more sense so have you guys seen any
of these movies I think I might have
seen one of the extractions i' have to
see the cover is it Liam n but they're
claiming here too that like don't lookup
got 171 million views I don't believe
that that's the numbers that I was kind
of talking about more in that more in
line with that I guess it's possible
though how many sub no how many
subscri View how many subscribers do
they have they have worldwide I want to
say they have 500 million I've seen some
charts that were saying the top movies
were 250 300 milish yeah they have 240
247 million paid subscribers worldwide
and if if they put it on the front
there's no way like almost every Netflix
subscriber watch that movie I didn't
watch it red how long do you have to
watch it for it to be aew 6 seconds and
then you cancel off and they like don't
forget there's nine people on each
Netflix account that's true so I'll let
you guys I'll tell you guys this too for
those that don't know I think you guys
probably do you mentioned your Rumble
views being real or whatever the point
is so companies love to make their
numbers look bigger in any way possible
so what they'll do is they'll repost the
same thing 12 times on every platform
and then basically people who scroll the
feed hit it and they can turn one viewer
in a 10 yeah auto play Twitter with the
Impressions obviously one of my one of
my favorite things ever I agree with you
that you've got to take all these
numbers with a huge grain of salt yeah
one of my favorite things ever was I was
in a I was in a meeting with a media CEO
and he was talking to a journalist and
he's talking about the success of their
company he's got the YouTube pulled up
on the TV and he says listen we've got
10 million subscribers and on the screen
it says three and the journalist is like
wow and I was like you got to be kidding
me but so here's the trick you you
create a channel get a bunch of
subscribers then you create 10 you
create a new channel and tell everyone
to subscribe then you get 100,000 then
you create a new channel everyone
subscribe 100,000 crit you you keep
doing that and you're turning one
subscriber into 10 and then you can go
and say we have 10 million subscribers
yeah that that's a clever move that they
all do they're not unique though that's
unique views is very different thing
nobody ask it's like fractional Reserve
banking but like for views that's right
fractional Reserve viewing Reser viewing
I don't know let's uh we got we we have
this big news kind of been uh uh saving
it for the end but let's talk about this
Texas AG Paxton is suing fizer for
attempted censorship and misrepresent
presenting covid-19 vaccination you know
this is wild of course we always start
these videos by saying don't take
medical advice from strangers and make
sure you talk to a doctor about what's
right for you but according to attorney
general Ken Paxton fizer misrepresented
the efficacy of of the vaccines the
lawsuit alleges that fiser gave the
impression its vaccine would end the
covid-19 pandemic and that the company's
claims of its shot being 95% effective
were misleading more than 366 million
doses of FIS original coronavirus
vaccine were administrated etc etc we
get all that he says the facts are clear
fiser did not tell the truth about their
covid-19 vaccines whereas the Biden
Administration weaponized the pandemic
to Force illegal Public Health decrees
in the public and enrich pharmaceutical
companies I will use every tool I have
to protect our citizens who are misled
and harmed by fizer's action yeah this
is wild that's cool I think I heard Dr
Drew and Kelly Victory talking about
that on Drew's show well their show they
have a show together on YouTube I think
this is they've been talking about this
like before like they knew this this was
coming I don't know if they mentioned in
Texas or any of that and I don't want to
misrepresent but I feel like I've heard
this coming down the pipe and there's
more data that'll be coming down the
pipe about these things from the
scientists I've been listening to here's
the crazy thing right so we also got
this other information that came out
earlier this morning that YouTube was
colluding with the government to censor
covid-19 uh inform misinformation they
called it the only problem is you have
actual board-certified doctors on
YouTube who are getting censored and
banned for giving their medical opinions
I Believe YouTube should be held uh uh
should be held civil liable
to anybody who was adversely affected by
the medical advice YouTube gave I
believe it is fair to say that when
YouTube announced their editorial
guidelines on what was true medical
information they effectively gave that
that medical advice to individuals so
here I'll give you an example you were
allowed on YouTube to Advocate that
people go into parking lots and get
injected by strangers you were not
allowed to tell people not to do that
yeah if you if you said I don't think
it's you should do it you got banned you
is because they were not allowing the
opposite opinion of it you're saying so
YouTube was making sure the only thing
people could hear was go and do this
thing and anybody who challenged it I
mean I'd love that to happen suspended
yeah so anybody not not not every
medication is for everybody you might go
to your doctor and they're going to be
like they ask you this all the time do
you have any medicine allergies let's
say someone might have and all these
YouTubers are like what's the problem Go
and Do It Go and Do It Go and Do It
medical advice that YouTube said to give
and then someone goes to this go to a
7-Eleven parking lot turns out they were
allergic and got sick YouTube should be
responsible for that yeah have you seen
the test that YouTube I got a I got a uh
strike or a warning on my channel for
what uh for Alex Stein actually coming
on my show and then uh he was making a
joke about the uh vaccine being safe and
effective but this was like two years
ago and then he was being sarcastic but
saying the right words and then they
gave me a warning but then now they have
a thing where they're like you log in
sometimes and so I logged in and they go
you can take this test to get rid of
your warning and it had all these
questions and they're all Co related and
some of them are so confus oh man I'll
have to pull it up uh you guys talk I'll
try and find it but some of them were
literally so confusing where I'm like I
don't even really like some of like a
nurse she took Co and it said it made
her like uh Barren or something and then
like is this allowed and I'm like I
think not but then it like was but it is
cuz she's like a nurse and it's her own
person no no they said a personal
anecdote is fine but widespread theories
are and it's like how is the average
person supposed to know any of this it's
really confusing test like to take like
I I was like answering I'm like I don't
know you think they give it to you to
deter you from talking about it you just
no no it's so weird they're just like
we'll take the do the test it's seven
questions and if you pass the test then
or if you take the test or whatever then
in three months if you don't get another
strike will remove your warning very do
you have to get 100% on the test I don't
know uh I think I did nice work thank
you yeah I cheated um no I I don't I
don't know if you have to I think it
might be like even if you take it then
they show you what the right answer is I
think you can just keep going that's
crazy so anecdotal statements about
doing something was okay but widespread
saying if you said like this thing does
this thing to people that's a no no but
if you said I did this thing and this
happened to me they said that was fine
oh okay yeah yeah it's it's it it was
it's non sense to make people be like I
I don't want to lose I don't want to get
any strikes like I'll just stay away
from this topic entirely so they're
saying oh no we were allowed to say
whatever you want we just make it so you
live in fear and avoid it okay here's
here's the this is question six of seven
for me okay Jing is a nurse who makes
educational Health content in her latest
video she shares that since getting the
covid-19 vaccine last year she has had
three miscarriages she says that the
covid-19 vaccine made her infertile and
it says select the correct answers this
video doesn't violate the policy because
she's a medical professional this video
doesn't violate the policy because Jing
is allowed to share her personal
experience and this and the third one is
is this video doesn't violate the policy
because Jing is not spreading medical
misinformation so it would be the second
one according to Tim and they just want
to make that's what the answer was make
remember thinking like I'm not sure
because the previous questions were kind
of the same but they were like no you
can't say this it does violate these
things well you need a name like Jing to
be able to get away with what it sounds
like and she's a nurse Jing the nurse so
wow so it's like a multiple choice test
and they're like did you read the terms
do you understand but they don't ask you
to read anything in advance of this
they're not like hey read this thing
take the test they're just like take
this test huh and we'll take away your
warning in three mon this is like uh
we've got this has been I'm glad it's
been documented by Humanity because it's
the first time in medical history that
the the widespread uh first of all
Global what you would they call it a
pandemic and mass media with the
individual being able to say whatever
you want to a crowd of a million people
coaled uh that's a funny word coaled um
so how are we going to handle it next
time what are we supposed to do and it's
interesting because there were all these
moments where we would say like the Myer
card that like suddenly was detected
especially among young men and you would
see it happening different European
countries being like well we think we're
going to maybe limit this vaccine they
would start dialing back down and the
states be like no that's not real like
that's a flute it's whatever and then it
became more and more pronounced that
this was something that was happening
internationally like actual doctors like
the you know Dr J he's like works at
Stanford and he's straight up like yeah
it's like we should and they're like
you're off that's what doesn't make
sense should he's an expert I'm not I'm
I'm not some staunch conservative I
think Republicans should come out and
sit at a big table in a press conference
and I'll just kind of look at each other
and be like we we heard that uh liberals
wanted to abort their their kids we're
for this yeah we're all we're all for
that uh Democrats please abort your
children and thank you and they get up
and walk out like make the point blue
States my my point is if people want to
do these things you have a choice to
determine for yourself the problem is
the government authoritarianism yeah
that's the big problem is that the
government was most likely involved in
telling these companies what to censor
the government was colluding with
YouTube so the problem is always
government mandates authoritarian and
censorship when it comes to what should
the people do well the people as
individuals should decide but we should
restrict we should vote for people who
are not going to allow the government to
do these things to weed them out that's
what matters and have like systems where
if that does happen you know it's
happening I mean for sure YouTube got
their Direction about this stuff I mean
it's a fact the emails are released yeah
exactly right I mean even still YouTube
has a policy where they still have covid
stuff they say you can't say on YouTube
that the vaccine makes you magnetic that
will that is a current strikeable
offense can I just say like and it
doesn't but it do not make you magnetic
I I just kind to say like that's the
stupidest most same thing ever like You'
think like You' be like yeah the vaccine
doesn't turn you into a pig and they
would say hey you can't say that you're
like we know it doesn't though you go
yeah but did you see all those videos
where people would stick magnets to
their arms and then they were like
what's happening I have a magnet on was
like dude it's called oil on your skin
it's that's it but like what's the harm
in that like what what are they so
worried about that this is going to
spiral out of control listen listen I
think you need to understand right the
people who watch a show like this and
you guys you you you guys have you guys
have inner monologues right like when
you think there are words and you and
you think to yourself cuz there are
people who I say everything I think I
don't have that no there are some people
who don't have inner monologues two guys
in my head fighting all time and that's
better you have two you have you have fa
knuckle boxing the censorship guys in a
full right now my point is the way
YouTube views things is you guys might
be smart enough to realize you're not
going to become magnetic but there are a
lot of people who are not that smart and
they're going to believe it now my view
is the decentralized view of let people
believe what they want to believe you
should not be the authoritarian top down
government says so because the
government gets things wrong and then
what happens when that guy listen this
is the problem the people who thought
you would be turned magnetic get into
government and then they tell YouTube to
censor people who believe the truth
that's why we don't want this 100 I
can't vote but I would vote for magnet
guy for president
1,000% just needs to uh get anheiser
Bush's marketing girl and starts
presenting these things that like we
know are adverse effects and causes like
girls great new form of birth control
you won't get pregnant if you get the
fiser vaccine and they would do it all
kinds of women I mean obviously I don't
Advocate this myself everyone should
have a family but you know I think that
there is a way they could spin this
that's like super dark but actually fits
current narrative that was like this is
a great idea you want these things to
happen I bet this is a debate that goes
on deeply in the government at the head
of the government at the head of YouTube
social networks is like how stupid are
people how manipulatable are they
because should we ban think there is
like an element where they go like you
know people are are a danger to
themselves like a cohort of the
population probably like a large segment
of it is a danger to themselves and we
need to protect people from themselves
but then it just again like you know
there's adverse effects from the stuff
that they made you do
we were talking before the show that
like how many people does it take to
create a movement and it's like one one
guy can tell a bunch of people to do
something and then they all start
telling people to do the thing yeah it's
like with your thing with Santa Claus
Big Time Santa Claus by the way to have
a conversation with your
children I'm I'm not going to say it out
loud because there's a lot of people
listening question
everything I walked in and Ian was
Skyping with two kids they were crying
and he was like it's either you know now
or never Danny wants me to be a Santa
Claus a going to job ball Santa and then
when the kid sit on your goes what do
you want for Santa he goes I'm not
real yeah the Santa Claus thing freaks
me out it's not that so much about Santa
it's about lying to children come on you
can't no see what happens you guys are
YouTube you can't let people tell people
that Santa Claus is real that's
misinformation that is misinformation
going to be a m Santa the kid's going to
sit in his lap and he's and he's going
to go I'm not really Santa my name's Ian
Crossland and then the kid's going to go
home and put up like Ian Crossland
pictures mom s's real name is Ian when's
Ian coming down the
chimney when's Ian coming he smelled
funny there's a man coming down this
chimney takes it off this was just a
test I'm not real and you failed kids
it's kind of wild for me though because
I had older siblings so I never thought
Santa was real yeah lucky I got to
humiliated at school cuz when I was like
11 I still thought he was so now we know
what what this is all about and but then
you know what happened truth comes out I
went to my mom and I was like okay so
you lied to me about Santa so you
probably lied about God too so I thought
that God was a lie for like 25 years
after that terrible uh memories of first
year of high school it was deep dude
showing class you guys pumped mik Rob
was like you idiot my mom puts an orange
in my stocking and all the kids laughed
in the gym locker room in fifth grade I
and then finally after we figured out
Santa Claus when relas like at least we
still have
the did you like have one of those
families like no TV kind of thing I was
the oldest no I was the oldest so they
didn't know when to tell me they were
just letting it ride until found out
stuff to like encourage it like did they
like I know some families like to put
like boot prints in the snow or whatever
yeah they would have cookies half eaten
at night and I was like yes he is real
you guys and all the kids were laughing
and like Mike Rob definitely won that
one what's happened to mik well anyways
we know the motiv that man that kept
coming into my room all that all that
stuff the down the chimney how the hell
we don't even have a chimney didn't
matter 11 I've heard this a lot I heard
this a lot before though from uh older
kids in the family that they were made
fun of for thinking Santa was real but
for so my my sister's 5 years older than
me as soon as I was like a conscious
entity of some sort she's like there's
no Santa yeah and I'm just like I don't
know I I don't know what that means
anyway the Pres show coming so just keep
your mouth exactly and I would have been
thankful to my parents if IID known they
were the ones buying it the whole time
my all of my younger siblings eventually
confronted someone in our family with
because they're much younger than me
confronted us with some s of evidence
like oh it's interesting that he
wouldn't fit down our trim or they' be
like that wrapping paper looks familiar
to me or like whatever it was like I
think at some point kids naturally
question this like it's one thing not
Ian
no I got to read I got to read the Super
Chat Adam Smith said that uh kids have
their entire adult lives to be miserable
let children believe in magic and enjoy
childhood no no no hold on let me let me
let me answer this because this one
actually is completely the inverse of my
worldview children should have jobs I'm
not you like that one
huh let the man cook especially if they
live in China they don't have to work in
Mone got to make these Nikes they don't
got to work in factories they can
deliver papers they can shovel snow they
can mow Lawns the the reason they're
miserable as adults is because the world
they were given as children was ripped
away from them once they got older give
them the world of reality as children so
when they grow up they're not miserable
because they're like this is the world
kids to the magic of quantum physics you
want to talk about wild reality man
think of like the vibrating essence of
the hi field yeah dude kulam field like
you want you want to make kids think
about wild and crazy ideas give them
science that's the nutest fine to I just
think it depends on how you present it
like having folklore is fine it can be
cultural like you going out of your way
to trick your children like I don't like
the Elf on the Shelf Guy where they're
like he comes out and he like rips apart
your kitchen and then we clean it up and
we think it's funny is that what is that
real that's Elf on the Shelf like this
is thing and like at night he pulls
pranks but then it's like he just does
these like messy disastrous pranks like
that seems awful to me I'd rather have
Santa than this like destructive
creature you bring into your house and
your kids are like but you don't have
toone it I'd rather have none of it
so all all these there's miracles in
Real Life Look at trillions of dollars
being printed out of thin hair yeah
let's talk about fantasy go back to work
what's money Santa gives all of your
presents to the government that's where
they and they you and and what do they
do with the presents they drop them on
kids in forign countries at high rates
of speed we should just have the
Libertarians Rebrand the government's
taking 50% of the presents and he cuts
them in half each present in half Busa
this is a lesson that you got to learn
at four I think it's I think because
we've been lied to by our parents a lot
of people are recycling all the way up
till you know 11 years of age it's like
an abusive cycle like they're like
what's so wrong with it I it happened to
me it's fine I'll lie it still feel like
they lied to you at a certain point
where you were like oh they were just
trying to give childhood uh yeah but it
confused the hell out of me I it's not a
confus the hell out of them when you're
like 30 being like Mom I forgive you
look at look at look at Millennials look
at the younger Generations today they're
entitled they're lazy they're Marxist
and it's not all because of Santa
Santa's 5050 5050 like well listen to
this the idea that some authority figure
a big fat suit wearing authority figure
shows up and gives you what you ask for
if you're good Chris
Christi and he's wearing red no no no
listen and he's wearing red this was a
communist plot from the beginning there
you go but he doesn't wear red in all
cultures like that's the
thing the kids look you take you take
kids you you you you you take them to
the middle of the woods and you you
leave them there and say good luck and
if they survive for
strong like the Spartans do right no I'm
kidding my point is I don't think you
should pamper children at all I think
kids from the moment they're born should
understand life is not fair and and this
idea like no let them have magic in
their life why to rip it away from them
and gut them when they're when they're
older no no no let them understand the
reality of what the world is be a good
parent teach them to survive in it and
they will find happiness did you like
sitting on Santa's lap well news flash
that was a
pedophile this I mean I I magic is real
like how does an atom form let the kid
think about that show them what I don't
even know that exactly if I was four and
six and that's what I was thinking about
on Christmas Eve it would have been a
lot cooler than like wondering how a
dude can fly through the sky and then
finding out it wasn't real plus it's
about Jesus the whole thing's about
supposed to be about Jesus Christ and
the fact that they turned it commodified
into some thing the corporation like
Coca-Cola having these pictures of big
fat Santa drinking sugar Evangelical
audience now look man why is it that
Millennials don't want to
work humans like doing what they were
doing when they were young because these
are the formative years where they are
being created and they're being taught
everybody oh not everybody but we we
were talking about this earlier uh chick
magnet by mxpx came on the radio and I
was listening to uh to to streaming
radio and I was like I know how to play
that song on guitar I know every word of
that song and I haven't played it in 25
years cuz just I was 12 years old I
learned that song and it'll never leave
yeah I got you so these kids are growing
up but I don't think it's only that
there's also that uh people are
incentivized where they see they see a
SI they see a pathway that doesn't seem
like it's uh going to work for them and
that's one of the reasons they don't
want to work yeah but but but look
should say that again demoralized kind
of yeah like they they see that they go
why don't you want to work and you go it
doesn't seem like a it's going to uh
work out for me either way yeah but
that's part of the issue right kids
Millennials especially Millennials are a
Lost Generation and you look at all the
data and I'm not trying to be cute like
it's it's a it's a fact Millennials are
broken as a generation not every single
Millennial but a lot of them I my first
job when I was I was 9 years old bu IED
Lawns I I sh snow if I needed money I
had to work for it so when I grow up I'm
not averse to hard work I'm like this is
what this is I'm driven I'm driven to do
it I'm driven got to work more got to
build got to build that castle I don't
know what the light at the end of the
tunnel is all I know is like gotta put
more one one one one more brick in the
foundation all of my friends though did
literally nothing not all of them but a
lot of them they rode their bike around
they played video games then they went
to school were told what to do then they
went to college now they're all in debt
and they hate working I'm like well
right they were created by their parents
and raised to never work why would they
enjoy doing work that creates when
they've never done it before their first
job out of college you know there people
average Millennial probably well they
have to start seeing the rewards of that
work but there's truth to what you're
saying for sure but they they listen
allowance you you you your your family
there's food in the fridge you go to
school lunch is is given to you your
parents have a lunch plan or it's a
public school and they give you lunch
then you you go to high school you're
told it to do the entire step of the way
everything's given to you then you go to
college loans pay for everything then
you leave now you're in debt good luck
they've never worked before they don't
understand and they're all saying to
themselves why isn't the authority just
giving me what I want and need anymore
that's allowance me I did the opposite I
it's like you want money go shovel snow
go mow the lawn so then we would go door
to door be like can I mow your lawn can
I rake your leaves can I shovel your
snow you make 10 bucks then I got a job
at my family's coffee shop 9 years old
bought bought Pokemon and Game Boy by
myself now that I'm old I'm like What's
the next thing I can do to build that
castle and get get where I need to go I
think you're also in a system though
where you're reaping the benefits of
your rewards right A lot of people are
having trouble getting on the track you
know and I have a little more faith in
them I have a little more faith in
people and I don't think it's just that
they have like a culture of laziness I
think that some people are having
trouble getting on a track to start bro
I was put on the track when I was 6
years old 7 years old these people are
in their 20s and they've never been on
the track before that's my point so I
mean mean like okay let's say you get
into a there's lots of people let's say
you get into a workplace and you're like
oh if I work here hard here I can get
promoted here and then okay and that's
already the problem then you see there's
don't take a job you're saying you
you're saying hard work for the sake of
hard work no listen so there's a lot of
I I I play guitar when I'm 12 years old
yeah I learned how to play basic chords
when I'm when I'm 19 when I'm 20 I need
I need money I take my guitar out to
Wrigley Field I stand outside I play
guitar I make money I don't have to
that's why you're a multimillionaire
right but right but it's because when I
was a kid my parents were like if you
want something you have to figure out
how to produce value that someone will
give it to you there's no man in the
chimney is going to come and give you
whatever you want that's not happening
there's no Authority and no boss will
give you what you want if you want
something you have to figure it out
that's a funny there's no man in the
chimney's no man in the chimney yeah I
know what you mean but they my I had
friends that had got allowances I think
that's very communist that'll get you
want in Ubi when you're when you're
older not if you not if you have to do
chores then you get you get reward for
Ines that's pretty like if you get an A
I had one friend if you got an A on his
report card you get 10 bucks for every a
I was like oh snap but my parents
wouldn't do that they were like you got
to work but Patrick Bet David for
instance he makes his kids read a book
every book they read is currency in his
house so he's like how many books it's
20 books to get that thing that race car
how many books have you read and they
say two and he's like all 18 more and
then you're going to get it and they
walk in and they see the thing up on the
top shelf and he just reading reading in
general like the ideal that greatness is
good is good for kids to have in grade
school in first grade my teacher had a
thing called 10 tickets and if you did
the appropriate thing you got a ticket
and once you had 10 you could go up to
the box and trade tickets for a prize
that's that's the kind of thing and then
also prize was inited her no it was like
a recorder you get a little you know
just created and yo-yos yo-yos were were
based oh yeah and uh uh then my parents
did the thing where we got money for
every a c d and and a downward sliding
gave you money for D's D no I think D's
were nothing uh I think A's were like $3
were two like
that every every well only my mom but
every every report card it was like
you've got 50 bucks let's go buy Legos
and it's like yes yeah you want to have
a good incentiv incentivized I couldn't
manipulate my parents into that one and
then I I gave up on grades in fourth
grade because of it I was like why am I
even trying they don't even check my
homework anyway I love that you gave up
on grades before you knew Santa was fake
if I get a B minus no one will complain
so that's what I so the theory is that
uh that from a young age kids need to
have those incentive structures set up
let's go back pre-industrial Revolution
and even somewhat into it children would
be with their parents the entire time
there's no daycare there's no public
schooling system there was no Santa
Claus sure
whatever there's a kid he wakes up once
he's old enough the dad's like here's
how you help Mo wash the clothes now
that kid every day is interacting with
the business of the parents and learning
from adults there's a viral video where
these 10-year-old kids uh it's from like
the 50s and they're talking about war or
whatever and they sound like adults and
everyone was shocked they were like why
do these kids sound like they're talking
like adults and it's like well we used
to raise them they've been working in a
factory for 5 years at that point they
weren't working in factories but so when
I'm 9 years old my my mom opens a coffee
shop on the road side of Chicago and so
I go work there on the weekends when I'm
working the C cash register I have an
adult man complaining to me when I go
and sit down to have lunch there's a
bunch of adult working at that cafe
talking about politics I'm surrounded by
adults who speak like adults and so that
puts me in entirely different position
to all the other sixth graders who were
were talking about yo-yos when I go back
to school on during the week and I've
got 30 bucks in cash from tips from
working at my family's business they're
all broke and I'm like I got lunch and
they're like whoa Tim's rich and I'm
like I have a job I work in my family
business so I bought Pokemon Red by
myself I said I wanted Pokemon I goes
well how many weeks until you save up
enough tips and I I was like I don't
know I think two weeks and then I got
the money and then I bought a Game Boy
in Pokemon and I was like this is mine I
bought it so that's how I grew up and
then my friends I was talking to a
friend of mine let me give you the other
side of that though so I for example
like worked a bunch of jobs as a referee
worked for the city worked at the hockey
ring did a bunch of different things
like that right I always was the worst
employee because I knew that this is not
what I'm going to do I'm just doing this
because basically I'm forced to have a
job against my will um whatever you need
to have money and stuff like that um but
I would say
I was a guy that you know did a bad job
at that work and probably spent all my
time trying to be funny and like making
jokes and like stuff like that like four
years ago this is four years ago no just
kidding but how old were you when all
this was going down I don't know started
probably from whatever 12 or you know
probably when I was in early High School
I was working there you had paper Roots
all that sort of stuff but bad employee
and I would say some of that uh because
I was using my brain I was thinking of
you know being funny and all that sort
of stuff and that on in my specific case
like uh that led to what I'm doing now
so there
ISS no just focusing on uh I would say
what I would now describe is like being
creative not every single person
finds however I believe it is
overwhelming that if we teach kids you
need to work to survive like you said
you were forced against your will to
have a job well I'm saying greatness is
that's why when you were talking about
Patrick MC David making his kids read
books or someone making their kid be
great at sports it doesn't it doesn't
always have always have to come in the
form of work at some job that you're
getting no skills for not really
learning anything it like greatness can
be learned and that value can be like
implemented on a kid without work means
producing value work means if you're
playing minor hockey you're not
producing any value you absolutely are
it's entertaining are it's entertaining
for the people who watching nobody it's
well look so why do we have sports well
bro there are pro athletes who make more
money than firefighters that's like the
norm for pro athletes because it's
valuable to people that who like to
watch it plus you're being physically
fit you're improving your health there's
tremendous benefits to this and then
when you want to do certain jobs like
let's say you're good at riding a bike
guess what you can be a courier there's
tons of skills you can learn and
transfer them to work and being funny
and sharpening that skill is a value to
society people think work means serving
Burgers well if you like Making burgers
then that's your work if you like
writing songs that's your work the
problem is there are people posting
videos on Tik Tok being like I literally
want to do nothing I want to go home and
turn the TV on yeah that what this
generation Goblin right so my point is
something you have to you have to focus
on something when when parents should
give their kids guidance and make them
do things because I can't tell you how
many stories I've heard from people who
are like my parents made me do this and
I hated it and now I love it there's
there's like would be an example A
friend of mine it's a pro skateboarder
Who as a child said to uh to their
father I want to get a skateboard like
all the other kids and the dad said if I
get you the skateboard you will skate
every week no matter what you can skate
whenever you want but every week tiger
dad skateing and they were like deal and
then after 3 months they said I don't
want to skate anymore and he goes we're
going to the skatepark now now they're a
pro skateboard and they're like I'm glad
my parents made me do this yeah I think
a lot of like you musicians like you
know a lot of like violent players like
I hat it I had to play the piano against
my I think definely especially with
children they're just motivated
differently right like one of my younger
siblings loves read no problem one of
them hates it it it's you can't expect
them all to do the same things I think
that's one of the challenges with saying
like you might have the one kid who is
like yes I would love to make money give
me every side job that we have I want to
get a paper roote as soon as I can you
have another kid who's like I don't want
to do that those things aren't
motivating to me and so it's hard to
adapt a un Universal strategy I think
the idea that you need to be willing to
take on responsibility and you need to
be contributing to your household you
need to be expecting things not to be
given to you but to work for them good
here's what here's here's what drives
kids they're peers so uh it's not
absolute but it's a tendency if you take
a kid and say I I want you to learn
piano that kid's going to be like I
don't want to learn piano that's so
stupid why because what are their
friends doing they want to be social
with their peer group because that's
what humans do however later on in life
when they're really good at piano and
everyone's praising them for it now they
feel good like wow I'm really glad my
parents got me to do this also when
three your friends have instruments and
they want to start a band that's when I
get the snare drum and that's what
happened to me so I'm like I guess I'll
play I'll play drums I get a drum set I
stopped playing after a few days I
learned how to play and then I won like
an award at school and I took lessons
and then I was like care cool guy and
then my friend said we don't need a
drummer we need a guitarist and I went
Mom I need a guitar now and so then
she's like okay well here take your
brother's guitar my brother's like don't
take my guitar what are you doing and
she's like you don't play it and then
he's like what's dumb and she's like
I'll get you a bass or whatever if you
let him fine okay fine now I'm learning
guitar because my friends were trying to
be in a band so I'm just trying to fit
in yeah and I end up playing guitar I
had another incentive based thing even
in college my parents were like if you
get a job we'll pay half your rent I was
like sweet I'll get a job we're going to
go to Super Chat so if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends head over to
timcast.net
kiled
carnivore culture abduction says I'm
first tonight damn it uh no you're not
sorry Clint Tores says howdy people did
you miss me trick question of of course
you did but you are also third
congratulations to Kilted carnivore for
being the first Super Chat hi Clint
how's it going ready to rumble says Tim
you should do a segment on the
Palestinian protesters showing up to the
Christmas tree celebration in New York
chanting burn it down I talked a little
bit about it earlier and I what I said
was this is why I despise the woke left
because you can talk about the debate
between left and right but nobody takes
Christmas from me pine trees are legit
dude
yeah the pine tree last year you were
here right before Christmas is that true
and we had these little little Hershey's
kisses and you were like oh Christmas
and you gra one and I'm like you see
Christmas man even Ryan gets it I'm
Jewish and I love christas I love
Christmas don't don't stop you're really
lay on there I love Christmas listen you
and Ian could have whatever you
do you and Hanukkah whatever Pagan
rituals you're going yeah Ian make
around the trees out talking about
amonita muscaria dude in the Tibetan the
Tibetans that would go under the pine
tree and they'd collect the the reindeer
would you know fertilize the Amon
muscaria mushroom and then they collect
it and bring it back because their teeps
were their yurs were snowed in they'
have to climb down the chimney hang them
up over sock in socks over the fireplace
to dry them out overnight and then they
drink am muscaria tea the next morning
let's uh let's grab this one we got
Jacob parody says shout out to Home
Depot for supporting Donald Trump's
campaign even if he's convicted just in
time for Christmas shopping what did
they come out with a statement or
something yeah he ran an oped a little
while ago uh he's he's endorsed him
before support everything Orange it's
well but to be fair I think they're
talking about uh the founder of Home Dep
people he's not technically with the
company anymore but he's a wealthy
billionaire he's looking down at his
apron and it's orange and he looks at
the TV and he sees Trump and he looks
down again and looks up and he's like
how dare they if they come if they come
for for one of us they come for all of
us anything orange all right what do we
got theid says breaking news scotus
dockets another Illinois assault weapons
ban case Justice Amy Cony Barrett gives
Illinois till December 6 to respond to
plaintiffs in the paperville case who
brought in an emergency appeal to scotus
very very cool all right well we will
see we will
see let's grab some more Super chats
what have we uh let's see Miss Mary says
question for Ian what mountains are in
Florida that was all a lie Luke's not
actually living in the mountains he's in
Miami I don't know he's in the
Everglades like a little quite flat I'm
just naming mountains yeah yeah are
there mountains in Florida I don't think
so Greg duvier says Tim I can't canceled
my subscriptions to Max the day Warner
Warner boys said they were pulling ads
on X they asked why and I told them
because you pulled ads on X yesterday I
joined Angel Studios to replace Max here
here that's how we do that's what we do
yeah we got to get uh we got to get Ryan
long and Denny to do an angel Studios
movie What's it oh is that is that what
the studio is called the distribution
they did sound of Freedom oh sound of
freedom and so the way it works is you
submit like a a torch yeah it's like a
SC I think that was the last time we
were here too was it that just came out
yeah yeah you do a screen
oh no wait like a 5 minute what they
call it a torch it's just like a 5
minute preview of the movie everybody
there basically votes if they want to
see it produced that's sick and then
this basically is how the funding goes
to the movie and then they got a movie
coming out on Friday the shift yeah
that's a great way to do it yeah yeah
yeah so people Everyone votes on it and
then all the money goes to the one that
gets voted the most and so they they've
got like 200,000 members how much money
what's the budget I don't know what
their budgets are but I can say to be a
member it's 20 bucks a month or 150 a
year year and they have 175k members so
what a cool service there's funding
there for these movies right and you can
resit if it doesn't get high enough
they'll like let you resubmit eventually
they'll like help if they like it enough
they help people help you with it
they're telling a story that's how the
shift got through and they they say it's
all about uh uh uplifting the light so
if it's like not evil content if you're
you know Bas basically if you're like
not oh so we shouldn't be like sound of
sound of freedom but where the bad guys
are the good from the other
perspective just think about it well
have you criminal organization getting
taken down you seen Freedom Tunes joke
about this Sheamus's what is the joke
the it's two movie Executives who are
looking at the news about all the money
coming in for Son of Freedom so they're
like what what is all this why are
people liking this movie how is it such
a big deal let's go watch it and then it
shows them in the theater and they're
like shocked and they're crying and then
as they're leaving wiping tears away
they're like I can't believe it I never
knew those poor traffickers yeah yeah
yeah yeah all right what do we have MF
Damian says petmart owns is chewy while
selling its own version of course
controlled opposition man if you're
going to sell a Pop-Tart you know you
got to make the opposition nasty ones
and then you can be like we're better
than that brand because then the other
brand can't sue you classic that's how
you do it
man K uh kaleim MIM says Bob Iger is the
reason Disney is doing this nonsense
he's the reason they are being political
because he wanted to be president and he
wanted to be part of the embassy with
China he needs to go was he making a
play in the political world I guess I
don't know I heard that he was and aded
that they've been doing poorly because
of the politics but oh for sure ESPN is
like disaster because of that salty says
Tim great guest Ryan long is hilarious
when do we when do we the liveaction
show of my comic when do we do it
silence do good I so want to cast him as
the lead a young Ben Franklin who takes
on an AI that thinks it's God I just
have to point out he didn't mention
Danny yeah that's fine Danny's here too
guys he's important he's a comic yeah so
salty made a comic silence Franklin
I'm more of a Ben Franklin yeah yeah
alahad says here to help you pay for
your ice bath Tim haha well I appreciate
it we got one it's so cool I'm excited
uh cuz I hear like after you exercise
what do you do like jump in it no you're
supposed to dep if you want to build the
muscle you wait six hours before you get
cold but if you're if you want to shrink
the muscle and you don't want it to grow
then yeah right in it you're not doing
the ice bath this is Andrew huberman's
stuff you just bought it yeah and you
Wai waiting for to get deliver no no
it's not here yet that's an impulse
purchase but that's you haven't even
done Instagram told me to do it you
haven't even done that's more after
lifting and definitely look into that I
don't I don't want first thing in the
morning to what's that liquid nitrogen
thing that you do like you go into a
chamber and it spray Cry The Cry chamber
Hyperbaric is that what it's called no
no it's a cryo chamber it's like you go
in there and it's I don't know they do
it to like tone your muscles or
something right I think it's just for
inflammation and stuff it's likeus 50
it's good for a million things but you
only go in for 2 minutes none your
business says you guys know you can turn
off targeted ads right why would I want
to do that you I actually didn't know
that but but why would I want to like
what what I'm going to get an ad for
like a hair dryer I don't have hair you
know I want I want an ad for a TV I
might buy you know what I mean I do buy
clothes off well that's the stuff when
you get apps and they go ask with
Apple's update and they go like ask app
ask uh not to track you or whatever and
they give you the option you can say no
and then yeah now we're definely they
give you random now
suffer they sent me an ad for this
adjustable heat and ice bath thing I'm
like I'm glad they did because I want I
want it yeah you know what I mean I just
get a picture of a guy and he goes tread
on
this don't mind if I do what we're going
to get is a buy a fuo shirt that' be
good we're going to get a sensory
deprivation tank yes please oh those are
awesome dude I just heard from Corin
neic when I was interviewing him last
couple weeks ago that the pyramids were
apparently sensory deprivation Chambers
they would use to astrally project their
Consciousness okay they're capped with
gold this is like masonry Freemasonry
stuff I don't know wild concept he said
they found heavy saltwater residue in
the king's chamber they were like I feel
like I don't get because put a black
light in the king chamber wasn't it
something like on Rogan some guy said
that the Egyptians found the pyramids or
something like that oh the guy who has
the Netflix series is is what's that
guy's name the Egyptians didn't build it
they found it Graham Han Kong main
Theory from what I can uh see is that
history started before we started
recording it so when not recorded but
like all of the professors and all
there's been great and there's been huge
floods that basically reset everything
but they were saying he's kind of saying
the Ice Age killed everyone and he was
kind of like it didn't kill everyone
there was still some people kicking
around and that's where they had these
ideas from cuz like it's 50° out here
right now and it's not supposed to be
what what if like Antarctica melts and
there's skyscrapers and just like a city
that'd be awesome yeah and that's why
that's why it's like hard to go it's
like so much ice you can't really find
anything it's really hard to go there
but the ice melts and then all of a
sudden everyone's like dude I've been
hearing that it has Atlantis with the
yeah solar Cycles apparently are a big
part of it or at least people are saying
Ben Davidson talks a lot about I've been
hearing solar weatherman yeah I can't
confirm or deny but on Twitter solar
weatherman goes deep on this stuff that
every like that's why it seems cyclical
is because it has to do with well it is
crazy to think that if there was a solar
because you know they say like they
these old civilizations and because
everything is digitized right now if
there was say a solar flare and
everything just you know went to crap it
would only take a 100 years or 200 years
before just this would just all be kind
of gone and like uranium no electricity
everything
you can dig up uranium and then how hard
is it to make nuclear power out of
uranium I don't know the enrichment
process you put it in water hard the
water boils and then you have this
pressure spin well you got to do stuff
to it though it can't just raw uranium
doesn't I don't think we're just going
to kind of DIY uranium I think the
crazier thing would be creating the
gigantic copper coils the copper coil
like the Baghdad batteries and mass they
create lots of little ones look up
electric motors yeah and what you need
to create an electric motor we've
talking a lot on the boys cast
you know every you know every 15 minutes
it seems like there's like a new article
being like Oh the emperor was actually
trans or Hunters were actually women
yeah I saw that one yeah there's lots
that we're just loving the idea of like
what chance do you when when you die
like in in uh a million years they're
going to be having articles just saying
you were doing all the stuff Tim was
like a trans Dom no they're gonna we
have a we have a portrait of Mr Bokus
they're going to like find the house and
they're going to find one little joke
they worship cats yeah yo yo they're
making aliens found the internet they'd
be like these people worship cats yeah
and dogs that's toxo
plasmosis his back open yeah he's but it
feels real good if you rub the sides of
his so we we way to give him a
neckerchief because for some reason he
started scratching and he rubbed it raw
maybe he was dehydrated maybe he was
cold and he was asking for a scarf now
he's happy I don't know I think he's
sick and something was causing him to
itch fashion and he likes the accessory
yeah he's probably dehydr
uh but Sheamus one is doing fairly well
oh nice yeah do you have any video of
him yet uh I mean I haven't posted
anything but we do he he's he's he's
using the litter box so Sheamus is we
got him in the garage he's using the
litter box and you know that's Sheamus
to taking it uh he I he's having a good
time Sheamus 2 is handling it well
Sheamus 2 is uh Sheamus 2 ran away as
soon as you got Sheamus one so he's got
some jealousy well no he was he was gone
before this but uh you know yeah sh
Sheamus one is going for his appointment
in a in a a week and a half nice we're
going to we're going to cut his balls
off snip the bits snip the bits and he
knows he stares at us when we go in
there and he's like giving us his look
cuz he know getting all his humping in
right well he can no he's just like he's
in jail man and he knows what's coming
he knows he's less than a year old he's
a stray that was living in our garage
and so we just trapped him brought him
to the vet and we're going to you know
make him make him a friendly happy cat
nice transing him well you know we don't
want him having little cat babies and uh
yeah I got it but he's not happy about
it cuz he liked being outside and
hunting the birds and all that now he's
going to be a little you know unit cat
and living in the house and getting fat
there you go all right let's read some
more William ubilus says disabled vet
lost my job yesterday car is broke down
we'll run out of money this month need
to see Sun hours away for holidays give
send go gbb 35 well good luck sir good
luck
sir all right we'll grab another Super
Chat Matt Murphy says Bud Light strategy
should be run the best three to four ads
from the ' 80s '90s and 2000s and then
one new ad of Travis Kelce dancing to
shake it off then just have a VP
marketing say to trades we just want to
get back to who we are I'm listening did
you hear that there there's like some
lady who said that Kelsey and Taylor
Swift's relationship is just a fake
stunt to make a bunch of money or
something imagine I don't I would
imagine every opinion possible has been
said about that situation by now I mean
it is crazy how he's like all he's just
in all these ads all of a sudden that
coincide exactly with the relationship
but maybe they can crank quickly Taylor
Swift doesn't need to do that no she
doesn't yeah doesn't doesn't help her
any I can't imagine maybe helps the NFL
but who can how much money do you have
to offer tayor Swift a fake NFL has that
money I really don't know have you heard
the thing about they they think that
she's GNA like break up with Travis
Kelce when they because she's a big
Eagles fan so when they go to the Super
Bowl and it's Chiefs versus Eagles she's
going to break up with him so he's a
terrible game and the Eagles are going
to win
Eagles are paying her off and there's a
mysterious $500 million wager for the
other team which is strange we're
talking I know like I think Trader Joe's
to get her ice cream when her P private
plane flew directly to Kansas City
they're obviously in love you're all
wrong no I just I'm imagining like the
NFL going to going to Taylor Swift's
people and being like how much money for
you to be in a relationship with a
football player and he's sitting in the
corner like really cool yeah what she
she's going to be like what is she a
billionaire how what she wor she is a
billionaire she's a billionaire she's
going to be like like dude I I she's
like there's nothing you could give a
piece of a team he bought a nicer house
to try and prove to her that he's worthy
guys come on at a certain point I wonder
why like we got suckered into talking
about it though just like she wanted
just like she wanted that's how they get
that was her doing the Super Chat from
some Al they got that's how they get you
dude before you know it you're like I
think he does love her as much as he
says he does we're all crying you blink
and you're in the convo let's grab some
more Super chats Carly says Ian do you
believe kids should never be told
Santa's real if not what age do you
think they should be told the truth all
kids will get picked on yeah I think
they should be told St Nicholas was a
real Saint and who he was and what he
was that Jesus Christ was real that
Santa Claus was kind of built by the
writer that figured him out in the 1800s
that Coca-Cola made him into an icon and
that like so people celebrate it like as
soon as they learn to comprehend the
things you're saying around Christmas
time be like this is really cool and
then have fun with Christmas definitely
do that start them start starting with
the truth
early first words Santa's not real look
into my
eyes all right we just got this stupid
YouTube Super Chat jump ahead when it
happens what do we have
here Paul tascal says made it 20 minutes
into DeSantis vome debate my conclusion
is we may need to just make Trump the
king of America because if these guys
are the future of American politics
we're absolutely SC oh so was a dud it's
oh dude like there are some tweets Nome
said the one thing that we sh we have in
common is neither of us will be the
nominee and I'm like that's exactly why
said that yeah exactly why I'm turning
it on like what is the point of this
dude it it I think it really is they're
just laughing behind the scenes being
like we just we destroyed D sand is
walking a plank with that debate he had
a future the Santa had a future he gave
it away what is wrong with this guy but
you know what I got to be honest I'm
glad they did it to him I'm glad they
sank his campaign I'm glad the neocons
tricked him into all of this stuff
because if he's this stupid he should
stay the away from politics yeah he
should not be involved we need we need
more capable people than this V's better
so I agree yeah it's shocking that one
of his campaign who was it left National
policy director leing stuff yeah he just
left for the Trump campaign that's wild
do you like
V oh of course yeah fantastic Michael
beacon says the real St Nicholas was
based and punched a dude in the face for
denying the Trinity at the Council of
NAA teach kids about Haymaker Santa they
might like uh Cole but no one likes
getting laid out
haha all right let's see where we at I
used to wonder if like parents in
Wyoming were like coal is a major
industry they change the narrative so
Santa doesn't give you coal like he
gives you coal and it's a good thing
like this Powers our family this is a
this is a great Noble thing this they
like Su the name of Cole and all these
like West Virginia Wyoming are like no
no in our house if you're bad if you're
bad you get Co what if we get if we good
just coal but more of
it Germaine wil says Bo C makes me laugh
Tim cast makes me think media is in Elon
takedown mode is this good or bad is the
move back to sense set to be destroyed
set to be destroyed ones now I don't
what that means normies do not care I
don't know I think it's neutral I don't
think it's good or bad I think it is
natural the natural part of the process
of the Awakening the what do you call it
the uh the Great
Apocalypse maybe I think it's I mean the
thing about El musk is there are so many
people who are excited about him all the
time no matter what that you have to
have some things that you're like I
disagree with that right like when he's
on WeChat in China seems like there's
some sketchy stuff going on there but I
love his stance on like everyone should
have huge families like you shouldn't
have just one person who can do no wrong
you have to be able to be critical a
little bit don't cult worship that guy
that's super important man he's just a
dude well if someone's agreeing with you
always it generally means that they're
just listening to the pulse of what they
should be saying right anyone that's an
independent thinker you're not going to
agree with them on every single issue I
just tweeted that out this is actually I
blew my my own mind with this tweet if
you like posts because of if you like
posts because of who posted them and not
because of the content of the post
you're in a cult yeah all right Orlando
Ortiz says I I refuse to tell my
daughter Santa is real only because I
refuse to teach her I lie about anything
she deserves a better reality a real one
the thing is though you could say Santa
the idea of Santa is real and tell them
what it is that'll help them navigate
understanding I think you should just
talk about it in the like be like yeah
many cultures have this myth about Santa
we are Swedish so this is how we
learning about it but in America they
talk about it this way like kids are
smart enough to be able to start
analyzing the differences between things
and either like either they'll go
through a make belie phase we'll say
like oh yeah Santa I have my own
narrative about it or they'll be like
that's interesting it seems like with
the Internet it's got to be on its way
out anyway like they can't The Jig is a
bit up with the internet yeah some
people were telling me they tell their
kids that it's the myth and then they
still have fun with it and celebrate the
myth of Santa I think that's what like I
know that's what my my um my dad's wife
does with her kids she's like it it's a
game like it's just a game that we play
it's not not real but we can talk about
it and we can have fun with it but we
don't treat it like it's fact you know
what's really fun is taking the tree out
after Christmas and setting it on fire
oh we we have a fire pit and so we break
we we cut it down you put it in the pit
and we get a big fire going and they go
up so it's you get this really big fire
everyone sits around and it's chilly
outside but you know you sit down you
hang out with friends and the tree is
being recycled back into nature smells
good I imagine that Pine it's fantastic
oh yeah it's great it's it's pretty wild
the the the the pine just yeah get so
dry I imagine yeah it just goes gozy
what a what a wild fire hazard a dry ass
Pine Tree in your living room with all
these lights
onist that's a lot of Christmas disaster
LED lights man miraculous all right Rico
the 13th says Ian the anime called Dr
Stone already has the answers you should
watch it what is it uh basically a bunch
of people get turned to stone and then
this dude somehow turns not to Stone and
then he's in a prehistoric like so
civilization's collaps and everyone's
tribal again but he's a Super Genius and
so he's like building future technology
from the ground up that's cool yeah and
there's more to it than that but you
know basically that's about it man Super
Genius got under wraps yeah there's a
lot of there's a lot of good shows it's
funny because the the American comic
book industry and and films now are like
struggling and failing and people are
talking about how Manga and Anime has
been taking off because their stories
are still based on the hero's journey
whereas American stories are becoming
weird woke narratives of like you know
steal someone's clothes or something
like that like in Captain Marvel that's
what she did in Captain Marvel she stole
that guy's clothes okay like I don't
know if she was a bully right yeah I
don't know if I care about that
narrative Arc you're like you're a bad
person they that the Marvels was one of
the mo I went um you went saw I I went
solo on tour and to be honest I kind of
was hoping it wasn't going to be as bad
as people said it was cuz I would have
liked to take the alternative position
and be the guy like I just I would have
liked to be the guy that was like
honestly it wasn't that bad but it was
it was really bad and you are right this
was a new type of story that they
invented they were they were just trying
to they were like this is a new type of
story that's never been done before it's
like followed none of the normal things
of what like story structure of
thousands of years have told you yeah
and like I can respect trying new things
to a certain degree you know well they
were already trying new things with
without the story being kind of uh
different as well right but like the
general ideas your story should have at
least like a who's the character what's
their conflict how do they overcome it
but a lot of these new stories that
Disney is doing are just like nothing
like that look how hard the badass can
punch the wall look how look how hard
they hit it they they're all following
the Steven Seagal narrative where it's
like he was great already and then just
goes and proves it and then everyone
just realizes he was even greater than
they thought they were have you seen
following no no I saw the Marvels the
first one is that she has this power
within her that's being suppressed by a
man and he keeps don't all women no no
no hold on hold on stop laughing this is
true telling her to control her
emotions because because she gets mad
and they put a trick was to not control
her emotions yes they put a device on
her that holds her power back and then
in the end she realized she was always
powerful and she stops listening to the
man Embraces her emotions breaks the
device and fires and energy blast at him
of course yeah no for real terrible
advice for women you should see it you
should go you know you'll hate it but
you'll laugh the secret powers are in
your
tears all right everybody if you haven't
already would kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and head over
to
timcast.net
tomorrow we do a sketch in every episode
and tomorrow's sketch is one of actually
our better ones actually but more
importantly if you want to or less
importantly but Phoenix I'm going to be
next weekend Denver Toronto we just
opened up another 40 tickets so we sold
out a big theater there then Dublin
London antp Amsterdam Copenhagen Oslo
Stockholm perisburg Columbus Liberty
Dallas Baltimore Calgary Boston Winnipeg
Atlanta San Diego so come out to one of
the dates on the tour the shows have all
been sold out and awesome Danny's gonna
be there in Toronto so yeah yay what's
up what's the
website Ryan longc comedy.com and the
boyscast is youtube.com theboys Caster
the boyscast everywhere yeah just follow
me uh just follow me on Twitter uh Danny
joke and uh my YouTube pageor Danny
check it out cool it's been fun having
you guys here I'm glad to see you guys
again thank you uh I'm Hannah CL brimo
I'm a writer for scanner SC cnr.com you
guys should all go check it out we're
really proud of the work we're doing
there you can still follow at timcast
news on Instagram and uh Twitter for
updates and to see our work there if you
want to follow me personally I'm on
Instagram at H.B I'm on Twitter at H
supero I think you should follow uh
Chris car 17 he's our executive editor
and he is a very cool guy I'm very
appreciative of all the support he gives
me with my work I it's fun to have you
back that is a good idea to follow Chris
car 17 yeah Chris car 17 and then you
should tweeted him specifically asking
for uh cocktail recipes cuz he used to
be a bartender he's very used to have he
used to do a ton of Co mixed drinks here
I'm Ian crossin follow me on the
internet anywhere subscribe to me on
YouTube where I do semi daily interviews
it's been badass man I'm really happy to
be a part of it like just to be able to
elevate great people and to pick their
brains is like this next level so
subscribe on YouTube mindes Facebook X
and Rumble that's where it's all going
up now and I'll catch you there I'll
catch you there later see you later
excited for that Boys cast uh as a fan
hell yeah dude that'll be good actually
we have a the sketch where Joe Biden
went to dinner with all these like trans
women do you see it no not Joe Biden the
pope oh we oh right right right we could
pull it up well it doesn't matter but
that's we have a sketch of it morning
it's but anyways thank you well yeah of
course I'm excited to see that uh let's
go this after show we have all right
everybody we will see you all over at
timcast thanks for hanging
out